[Music]
thank you
yo-yo mic check mic check live from the
NZXT
um
[Music]
what's up it's too loud
turn down a little bit how my levels how
my levels what's going on NZXT
represents astral pirate king flame
what's going on talk tonight sounding
good sounding good I had to talk to the
people
question question
emergency
[Music]
second round
foreign
[Music]
today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
you just wobble to the car that's right
that place has the swimming pool the sun
come out to see me
we gonna fix that in a minute but give
me one second you know my checks off
real quick
hello hello hello cool cool cool I just
want to say anything about it
looked like Mr Magoo
it's only set for you so uh go over your
box and it should let you uh resize it
to another one there'll be another
option all right there's one of them
little little resizes what's that beefy
fluffy like
there we go
yeah it's that emergency podcasting on
the Fly I'm surprised he ain't put on
the white coat Energy
[Laughter]
emergency situation powered by NZXT last
minute you know what I'm saying so look
man y'all know what it is we gonna get
right into this here you hear ye welcome
to the emergency broadcast system of the
I lost podcast live and Direct on a
Tuesday what are we doing what's going
on
fantastic
yeah yeah it's crazy it's crazy right
here but we got it we got to talk about
this is a Code Red emergency podcast the
biggest leak in Xbox history so
obviously the realm wants to talk about
it we did have initial plans to wait
till Sunday but because of the nature
most likely of our guests and all the
other things we got going on we just
figured hey let's just get right into it
so uh yeah let's introduce those Lords
here I'm gonna start actually with soft
first live from an undisclosed location
how are we doing sir
I I like to apologize in advance I'm
coming to you guys live from a bunker
today because uh I'm the one who leaked
everything
oh you're on the Run you're on the run
I'm in hiding I'm in hiding so you know
okay you know I'm gonna let y'all know
the real real from where I am but you
know yeah we can't do that right now
apologies for this for the sound though
yeah we appreciate you brother we know
right now
the feds are on you it's real hot right
now
brother this is true loyalty this dude
leaked it we still messed up
I gotta send you this inside the chat
you're going to pass out please look at
that what you said right now you you
gotta read what somebody posted under
the bottom
ah
no no
a lot a lot of a lot of fears and dreams
for some and fears for others have been
uh have been released
we want your boo oh man this is gonna be
okay I'm looking for your honey
let's shout out my codes to combo Lord
addict how we doing sir emergency
broadcasting system this is not a test
yeah and keep in mind yeah you're low
you're low you low I'm low yeah yeah
yeah now you're a little better now that
you're up on it you know what I'm saying
yeah put that mic up on you you gotta
get up on it well I think I think what's
going on is uh they they where I have
this new computer they're probably oh
yeah okay or what about now yeah yeah
keep talking all right is that fine is
that fine is that fine what it was is
the computer was uh hijacking my uh
volume uh so yeah this is gonna be an
interesting thing man we we
this this is uh it's it's horrible for
Xbox but it's good for us it's a crazy
time right now let's just say that for
sure for sure that's a dog food it is a
crazy time we're gonna try to break down
as much as we can and then of course you
already know the Incredible Hulk of this
Xbox's future General you already know
hold the line movement bro little King
how are we doing I'm doing incredible
what
[Laughter]
get some tweets out let people know we
outside because uh this is a rare
occasion for the Lords obviously on uh
on this emergency broadcast system right
now
hey chat chat man as you can see below
but below the little uh you know the
caption there's a share button yeah yeah
all right I want you to click that share
button and click that that I I
YouTube hasn't fixed it it's still
Twitter so on on YouTube I want you to
tweak this link on that Twitter man
let's let's get this out to as many
people ain't used to us on Tuesday you
gotta inform them we gotta let them know
you have no losers outside so let's see
what's going on but um look sorry for
eating y'all
apologies it's not professional
podcasting but um no we got to talk
about it this is an average podcast yeah
this is this is something that again
came again at the last minute but it was
one of those things so let's try again
we decided we was going to go live an
hour and 10 minutes ago exactly so let's
try to get to it as best as we can so
look obviously uh shout out to Wario 64
you know last night um about maybe 1am
Eastern you know a ferry of uh news
information started to be released and
um it first started off with um code
name Brooklyn
we go hard we go hard
Brooklyn yo you know what it mean that
means they got on them high Tim's energy
they gotta beef and broccoli business
right now they doing thick man I'm in
trouble he said Brooklyn well you know
what Brooklyn dude you know think about
it really think about it
Manhattan keeps on making it Bronx keeps
creating this Brooklyn keeps on taking
it
the whole name is Brooklyn so yeah I
mean obviously we learned about an Xbox
series X refresh you know code name
Brooklyn I'm not going to go into every
single bit of detailed here but um
updated Technologies Wi-Fi six that uh
looks like kind of like a cylinder
design you know or um will deliver 4K
gen 9 console gave me more storage
faster Wi-Fi reduce power more immersive
control and beautiful redesign so
there's a lot of things to unpack with
that but that was kind of like the gist
of it on that front and then went on to
uh I don't know if I'm pronouncing this
correct code name siebel yeah yeah it
look like that it do look like this and
I got it already and I don't want y'all
to even know about it I got the White
Edition
you got big white man for series
so we got kick on that and then um in
conjunction with that was called siebel
I believe new Xbox controlled the
world's best control playing on the
screen near you while it's two uh while
Xbox wireless two direct to Cloud
Bluetooth 5.2 a whole bunch of mobile
app features on Precision haptic
feedback accelerometer quieter buttons
and thumbsticks durable um rechargeable
swap of battery repair disassembly you
know um same ergonomics is Merlin I mean
sort of Merlin is the last uh code name
lift to wake y'all so a minute you you
know you lift it up you have the
controller in hand against some type of
sensibility there for that and uh yeah
that was pretty much that kind of has
like a series s feel at the top with the
white and the black you know kind of
kind of like the uh new Elite kind of
thing white black kind of thing but yeah
so we had that and then
um pretty much you know the mid
generation lineup you know as far as um
code name for series s's looks like L
wood codename for the refresh of series
X is Brooklyn again I'm assuming Elwood
is we're gonna say little Blackness
because what is it yeah it sees the
physical store at 512 to one terabyte
you know kind of what we know about
Wireless two
um shout out to Wi-Fi six y'all I was
kind of happy about that shout out to
Wi-Fi six and um yeah you got you know
you got that and then there's um Uther I
don't know what this is um Xbox series X
go name Ethan are you stupid they're
dropping
I know what that is yeah so again it
kind of like a whole you know siriusx
and xdl and then Universal controller
for both um code names and yeah you know
we got that and then what else there's
so much going on then we had launch
timelines you know what I mean far as
when they were talking looks like they
were thinking about next year and then
Elwood with the one terabyte launch
again that's the revamp Series S 299
Brooklyn again which we talked about uh
two terabyte launch looking at close to
November and yeah they had like a 60-day
separation yeah all digital good points
off good point All Digital they had a
road map for this whole thing a whole
bunch of improvements there and then I'm
gonna go on because we have a lot of
leaks y'all this is crazy
um again Wario 64 said it's gonna be
preface this this is this is not the
lunch I bet you that man wasn't
blacklisted that Avatar's blacklisted
now Wario 64 right after that you know
pretty much had kind of like a a road
map as far as the schedule is and this
again looks like bethesda's plan and of
course or now mind you the years are
different this is saying uh fiscal
quarter year 20. a lot of this stuff is
either come out already but this was the
initial plan pain that it looks like
they had covered up yeah before coach so
fiscal year 20 do maternal and DLC you
know which one I think we did get Elder
Scrolls Online graymore
um I believe so Fallout wastelanders and
death Loop so death Loop was supposed to
come out then and then obviously the
mobile aspect I'll leave the mobile
stuff alone for right now
um their fiscal year 21 uh star field in
21. 2021 was supposed to come out Elder
Scroll expansion red fall 2021 was on
bethesda's list dual maternal DLC
ghostwire Tokyo 2021 uh fallout worlds
project hibiki don't know what that is
now for 2022 the plan was the Indiana
Jones game uh Oblivion remaster which is
very happy to see for a lot of people
wanted to know about that it looks like
it it is real it exists
um Elder Scrolls Online expansion again
and Starfield DLC so starfish and the
DLC is talking about the following year
2022 which obviously we know what
happened it didn't come out supposed to
come out
the fiscal year 23 Doom year zero
project Kestrel hmm I wonder what that
could be maybe because Bethesda one of
these got to be Hi-Fi rush but we're
going to need that alone
um Elder Scrolls Online expansion again
Elder Scrolls getting all the content uh
project Platinum very interesting name I
don't know what that's about and then uh
fiscal year 24 Elder Scrolls 6 project
Kestrel expansion uh licensed IP gain
Fallout 3 remastered Elder Scrolls
Online expansion ghostwire Tokyo sequel
as for me and an attic for you dis and
solve Dishonored 3 officially written
down that is a big one that means that
when the death Loop team finished they
probably went straight to dishonor three
Dishonored three and then Doom here zero
DLC and then uh we still continue uh
again
you know plans uh let's be honest of
Beyond just this is why the leak is so
massive it it's beyond just the next
year in the mid-gen refresh we're now
talking future console you know console
generation I thought it wasn't gonna be
a window
well yeah it looks like that the
commitment to console is still there you
know again shout out to Wario 64 because
he said
okay we had a statue's limited you got
to protect the IOP released in 2028
Cloud hybrid games
um potentially switching to arm from x86
um so I've been talking about cohesive
hybrid compute Cloud to Edge
architecture across silicones yeah shout
out shout out to Crackdown three
that may fear it has some people scared
but we'll talk about that graphics and
Os enabling ubiquitous play now this is
another solve for buzzword term Ai and
machine learning enablement optimization
and acceleration of game performance
operations and developments for players
and creators and then on Creator
platform open and extensible game and
immersive app development platform and
it goes on I mean the extent I mean this
the extent of these leaks this literally
feels ripped off the actual whiteboard I
mean they have
um basically things labeled in game game
performance game experience Creator
efficiency player service and live Ops
then what's highlighted in green is
actually what stuff that's established
already in Microsoft gaming stuff that's
in yellow is kind of research and proof
of concept and stuff and gray is
actually further fertile future ideation
so a lot of things still have to be in
play but this was part of the vision so
I'll just talk about what's established
projects in gaming you know for right
now for game performance they talked
about super resolution deep neural
networks so that seems to be the closest
as far as this future for that
um I don't know what frame rate
interpolation is solved I don't know if
you can help me out there I think it
just it feels like this Frame insertion
stuff right so it's like it's yeah you
know basically smoothing out smoothing
out the uh the frame rate by inserting
frames and and in in spaces right so it
kind of Smooths everything out the stuff
that we're seeing right now with you you
know whatever dlss and FSR just again
right I feel a lot of it the stuff that
they talked about with this gen is stuff
that like big buzz words that get people
to be excited about it but as we've seen
like a lot of that stuff just it's just
now to come into play right yeah um in
very minor way so again this is just
dumb
that stuff coming to fruition and really
being a part of the ecosystem now yeah
as opposed to in the beginning it's just
kind of buzzwords and they hope to get
that stuff on they're saying like Ray
tracing and stuff like that you get some
stuff with it but it's you know it's a
high cost to it it's not something
that's super integral to the experience
hopefully moving
oh yeah
you may have lost sounds okay sorry back
so um yeah we got that and then um
xcloud latency compensation yeah
we got you back this is what happens
when we get bunker exactly listen you
want to run bro you want to run you did
what you did and now we got to protect
you so you you and Wario 64 running a
tight ship over there but uh I might be
Warriors
okay and then obviously 64 watching the
podcast he is all the smoke goes to him
and then obviously xcloud latency
compensation that's in proof of concept
as far as game experiences they talked
about AI agents codex and uh RL based I
forget what RL is I'm losing that right
now but again proof of concept what's
established matchmaking player ranking
we know they're they're excellent with
that kind of stuff uh Creator efficiency
we got AI game testing procedural
content generation physics inverse
schematics NLP dialogue Generation all
in proof of concept stage player
services or safety and toxicity uh
personalization Discovery Support
Services all already established they've
been excellent in that kind of stuff
already they've been showing that stuff
with the voice messages and stuff and
then live Ops they talk about engagement
and retention management monetization
Improvement Cloud resource optimization
so as we continue on at the leaks
um shout out to idle sloth because he
put this law
um this you know conversation that came
up was about Game Pass and Game Pass
engagement and uh looks like Game Pass
subscribers play 14 hours more than
non-game pass subscribers per month Game
Pass subscribers also spend 23 dollars
more than non-game pass Subs per month
so we have that engagement I thought I
thought I thought we don't play games
and we don't buy games I thought I
thought we didn't do these things
these leaks is kind of crazy yeah there
was also you know comments about
um Phil
again shout out to Mario 64. I was stop
with it but um yeah apparently
um at some point filming a comment at
some point getting Nintendo would be a
career moment and I honestly believe a
good moment for move for both companies
it's just taking a long time for
Nintendo to see that their future exists
off of their own Hardware a long time so
yeah that that came out there and uh
that's how these streets when how
Nintendo feels about that so we got that
aspect and then um I do want to speed
past because I get it so much
um there was actually we'll get into the
responsibility I'll actually leave the
responsibility for the next topic I do
want to bring this to King no I thought
this he would take great interest in
this part shout out to The Verge
um oh yeah Microsoft uh react the leak
also discussed their reaction to the
PlayStation 5 reveal and um yeah
according to senior leadership and you
know after they showed you know know
they just announced um PlayStation 5
um yeah he said we they said that they
would expect to have a 30 advantage over
the PS5 on GPU GPU performance at a 25
memory bandwidth advantage in terms of
real wild performance this was Elizabeth
hamrin from Cedar leadership
um yeah and then you know Phil went on
to say you know how he was very
confident about you know after seeing
what they saw you know now he did they
did give
um part of the redacted chunk as far as
Sony the long-term price advantage on
expandable storage which proved to be
true because they went with the what is
it the um the standard slots right as
opposed to the proprietary regular nvme
yeah yeah so they talked about that that
would be advantage and then um they did
um talk about obviously they felt they
had the the teraflop advantage and stuff
like that and yeah I mean pretty much
you know after looking at that reveal
um Phil was kind of confident he said
almost after 12 hours of talking into
their unveil taking apart their specs
and looking at the community responses I
just want to say that I'm proud of the
team and Satya Nadella young Odin jumped
in said it's really great to hear Phil
neither of us have announced pricing yet
and this was right during that time so
look there is a ton of stuff here
there's a ton of stuff here I just want
to talk about you guys can take it any
way you want I want to start what you
saw because I know time is limited
um
so take it from any angle with all the
stuff that you don't pause
um what what are you Gathering from um
these leaks that was the craziest pause
I've ever heard it was that crazy I
could take it from Eddie angle it was
wild crazy it was super pause
[Music]
I didn't even I'm searching my leak mode
pause
how crazy that stuff I didn't realize
how crazy
I don't do good on Tuesday I'm usually
good on the launch days
this Tuesday
[Laughter]
well I mean I I think the first thing is
just like completely gobsmacked like I
was up when when they started coming
through
um because yeah we noticed I went home
yeah I was up because I was um I was
super sick last night and I went to bed
and I think my wife
well keep going accidentally get back in
the caffeine I couldn't sleep
so I was up and at Dragonheart Yogi
started uh texting me yeah he sent me
like oh wow and then I saw that and then
then I saw it from from Warriors
physically and it's funny because Tom
Warren before anybody started saying hey
um apologies in advance for all the
spamming that's gonna happen because I
got a lot of stuff to say and I guess I
guess Wario will be into the punch
um but I think for me first thing is
like it it's a it's a sad day for the
people yeah first party over there on
Xbox then yeah have their work out there
in the streets and are not able to now
control The Narrative of when they want
to talk about the stuff how they want to
talk about it
that's a sad thing that's a sad thing
because again there's people who who
talk to everybody on all sides of the
industry we know how special it is for
them to be able to you know talk about
this stuff on their own terms when
they're ready to talk about it
um and that's been taken away from them
right and to the Revelation now that it
was sort of of their own doing and I say
them because we don't know who it was
but obviously it was internal as opposed
to the ftc's doing
um it was just a very very bad mistake
that obviously is going to have
repercussions so with all that said I
mean again it's a sad thing for them
actually it was a it was a court uh
Court Clerk who did it I mean it's so
conflicting because let's save this part
of who did it yeah we can point fingers
at that person we don't need to do that
what did you guys do it I got a picture
of them so we will we don't get deep
into that
let's save that for the next point after
that picture I got I got the the face
yo hit that like button y'all I'm happy
to give the the the blame to somebody
else but yeah so when all that said
though obviously this is super super
interesting information yeah and it's it
is the craziest thing I've ever seen
because yeah you literally have their
entire road map pretty much for the next
decade out in the streets
um and looking at it it's obvious one
thing is obvious that they were affected
by Kobe right because a lot of timelines
for the games we're talking about are
super behind right so um so all that
stuff is now what that means is that a
lot of that stuff feels like it's more
eminent than ever because they had all
that time to work on it or an oblivion
remaster a Fallout remaster
um this new Doom whatever it seems like
that stuff so when they talk about now
like hey
I can see now that every four month
Cadence we go oh every three month
Cadence we're going to start having a
game it makes sense because all that
stuff has been backed up and on the back
burner so
um that that's kind of interesting to
see now on the hardware side yeah I
didn't really start to compare specs
right but in terms of specs that you
guys look back so the refreshes are just
you know they're adding Wi-Fi sticks
they make a lot of quality of life uh
changes right
um Power efficiency obviously the size
of the consoles and kind of like uh you
know uh redesigns of the consoles but
they are more powerful right so these
are refreshes in terms of look and sort
of internals yeah but Power Wise It's
not a it's not an you know a pro version
Yeah so basically Phil did not lie about
right it's not doing it uh because
remember that the talk was obviously Tom
Henderson's out there in his team they
had put out the PS5 Pro information that
info we knew that was going to be around
that timeline but from and then when
they spoke to Phil around that well and
he was like no we're kind of content
this generation we're not going to do
kind of like the mid game refresh but
when you look at this this is not truly
like a upgrade yeah this is more like a
like a slim refinement version right
it's it's the redesign that you expect
sort of mentioned where it's like okay
we can we can now manufacture this for
cheaper
um we could make it smaller more power
efficient things like that so the things
that they're adding are cool but it
isn't you know the games will play the
same or whatever the case may be
um so yeah that's that's very cool
because
um a product of
where we are with covet because I
honestly believe that none of these
machines have ever even got close to
reaching that potential I I believe you
know Forza will probably be the first uh
this year game
um pushing whatever the hardware can do
from what I've seen so you think that
that's the reason why they like you know
what we don't need no more power because
we didn't even tap into the power that
we have yet well that's the truth I mean
again we talked a little bit before
about the buzzwords stuff the FSR and
all that stuff that was supposed to help
these consoles punch above their weight
we haven't really seen it in a real way
at the start of the gym there are a
whole bunch of buzzwords that they kind
of expect us to want to be excited about
and then it sort of disappears into the
background and then and you know all of
a sudden you start hearing all this game
music this game music but it uses it at
a hardware level it's not controllable
by the by the by the user right by the
end so the expectation is that you know
on the PC side obviously that's in your
control so moving forward I think that's
kind of where they want to go where they
give you that option on the console side
and again it may not say FSR or whatever
but again looking at the the different
sort of uh performance modes and things
of that nature we'll get more and more
of that stuff that's the hope so but in
terms of what these consoles are I think
this right on par with what everybody's
been doing you will always get that
mid-gen or sort of refresh of the
hardware that allows them to manufacture
it for cheaper yes
um if they can make it smaller and more
power efficient
what I can say is it fits perfectly in
your hand
um it's very efficient
you could
from what we've seen of these designs
they look very cool and small right
um so it that that's cool and that's to
be expected right um and that that's the
type of leak you sort of expect to see
something that that's like a year out or
something like that so that stuff is
cool now what what really just was
eye-opening is the fact that like like
you said like the entire roadmap for
years and years and man when we start
talking about future Hardware past the
series X uh what's interesting is this
idea that they're going back to that
idea that they introduced during the
Xbox one generation which was this
hybrid sort of uh model where they
utilizing Cloud power in conjunction
with local power to give you experiences
that can't otherwise happen locally
um even if you have a super powerful
computer right when you're talking about
these these Cloud situations
we go back to all of these buzzwords
that they use secret sauce and all that
stuff where they introduced it in the
Xbox one generation knowing full damn
well that they were not going to be able
to achieve that level we got a double
solve we have buildings breaking me they
told us that it was it was a very
controlled environment
that when we saw when we saw that
Wrecking mode wrecking crew in the
actual game it was not that it was cool
for what it was it wasn't that
so again obviously they have confidence
in this Tech and it can be something
somewhat transformative because the fact
is that they're banking their next
console to be sort of uh rooted in this
sort of tech that's that's super
interesting because it means they got
something right right they're going back
to that well after you know you can
assume that a lot of people were
disillusioned by the fact that stuff was
not necessarily true in the Xbox one
generation
um so it's interesting that they're
going back to that stuff and again
disappointing that that that stuff is
out there now in a way that you know
narratives are going to be created
around it without them being able to
speak on it how they want to so that
stuff's interesting though I don't know
what you know
as we're using more and more local power
right obviously now we have these PCS in
the house and we've been talking about
other PCS you know 40 90s and things of
that nature these are very capable local
machines that can do a lot of cool stuff
right um but again the cloud Tech is
something that everybody's focusing on
everybody is kind of this is the Future
No Matter What whether you believe in it
or not everybody's focusing on it in one
way or another so the fact that they're
kind of banking their next-gen console
on on sort of being a pillar of the
clouds of being a pillar is super
interesting and and we'll see if how
that pans out now now the third sort of
aspect of all of this is the emails and
all the stuff and the conversations
behind the uh behind the curtains and I
think it we have to say first of all
beyond the shadow of a doubt there is no
doubt whatsoever the idea of Bill
Spencer as a nice guy you can get over
on them smiley smiley is out the window
I think
with with Game Pass
the idea was create a platform that
allows us to rule the world
little by little continue to add to that
until we have everything when you talk
about the FTC stuff right I I think Lena
Khan said something to the effect of
Life yeah you know um a lot of these
smaller deals that sort of fall out of
our purview allow a lot of these
companies to sort of continue to uh to
sort of build up
they're controlled of a certain sector
without us necessarily being aware of it
because these are all small purchases
piecemeal here and there that overall
over time like zombie stuff exactly
exactly but it's stuff that they all do
right because why would you not want to
continue to build your strength in a way
that's not being uh monitored by the
Watchdogs right so
she talked about that and the fact is
that the idea that you know we're
talking about you know Phil's comments
about a Warner Brothers and obviously a
Nintendo oh um
super super bullish in this idea that
hey everybody's for sale it's always a
conversation to be had
usually it's a money thing or an
ideology thing right obviously because
the comments around the Nintendo were
very interesting because it's like it's
one of those things like Nintendo wants
to be sold they just don't know it yet
so again
and it's funny because Phil came out and
addressed a little bit he was like Hey
if it's kind of sad you know yeah stuff
is stuff has changed so all of this
stuff is out of context and not the
realities now because if you look at it
like you know this idea that he they
wanted to really you know 2020 Nintendo
uh kind of you know hey their their
future isn't on their own Hardware their
own Hardware is selling like you know
like hotcakes and you know if they
continue to stick to this hybrid model
there's no reason to believe that it's
gonna change with the next iteration of
you know whatever the next platform is
right so this idea that like nah
forget about all that your the your
reality at some point in the future is
you're going to be a third party or
you're going to be uh exclusively making
software and not doing Hardware so
um it's going to be interesting to see
how that affects the relationship moving
forward now that this is out yeah that's
a good point no conversations that were
not to happen
it's like you know I you know you see
Bowser and you know the the Nintendo
Japan were like oh really
this is what you this is what you think
we are right so it's yeah it's one of
those things that is a conversations
that are not supposed to be out in
public and all of a sudden now you know
there might be some awkward emails and
conversations back and forth about
awkward about it what is the meaning of
this okay
[Music]
you signed the paperwork so when they
sign the paperwork she it was like I
told you she want to be wifed up right
now
his baby steps is working towards it
yeah use the words baby steps today
so I mean it's a to conclude my part of
it yeah um like I said this is quite
frankly the largest sleep I've ever seen
period I love this period period and
again as a Content creators and people
that talk about the industry you know we
ain't good today yeah at the same time
it's like okay on the Microsoft side you
gotta you gotta see okay what what do we
do now because obviously this is all out
there plans can change right absolutely
but it kind of does feel it kind of does
feel like it was their route and whether
they continue with this as is or make
changes to it because you know what
that's as as fans right we sometimes we
talk about like oh why is it you know
gaming industry so secretive and the
fact of the matter is this is what this
is
when you talk about movies that you know
aren't secreted if you know that the
next Batman or Spider-Man movies coming
years down the line whatever the case
may be it's different because here when
you're talking about the Confluence of
Art and Tech if your stuff gets out
somebody could look at it be like I'm
gonna beat you to the punch say that
thought that's gonna be that's gonna be
third topic three and so the idea that
this stuff is out there so many years in
advance you know Jim Ryan and everybody
that's doing this look like okay okay
this is what they were going to do do we
do we have to do we have to start
thinking in that route or maybe they
were thinking in that route already or
maybe they were they were thinking in a
completely different direction that now
makes them you know do a double take and
be like okay
where is the future going and what do we
have to start I know if they don't know
where the future is going and they are a
billion dollar company then they really
need to fold up faster
all right so this leak ain't make Jim
Ryan go yeah this is what's happening
over there no not to agree
for the most part I would say there's
some things on this list that Jim Ryan
didn't know but I would say for the most
part they knew the direction uh that
this was going to go eventually and I
think when you look at Sony's reluctance
to sort of follow suit completely right
because they they
get Elder Scrolls six yeah that was the
only thing on that leak that they saw
that they said oh hell no not again
yeah that's what I forgot it a
definitive sort of knives that happening
it doesn't count as Legacy
um yeah so uh again I'll I'll let you
guys talk yeah I'm gonna move around and
I'll try to do it when I can no doubt
but uh yo crazy it's all crazy make sure
if you see a red dot you dip oh yeah the
head low head low bro hello
thank you outside
you know I was prepared for this though
I'm always ready you know always in the
street BX baby yeah
they don't come up to the BX unless it's
unless it's meaningful
now reach him like I'm gonna hit you
with when we need you but let me get at
it because you've been quiet and um yeah
bro we was up pretty late obviously
we're configuring yeah I got in trouble
for that yeah new PCS you were helping
me out you know so yeah what do you
think there's so much to unpack like
what do you think of anything what are
your thoughts of these things man
I think for the most part
the biggest thing that I think that they
didn't want out there is maybe Sony was
curious that they were going to do a
mid-in refresh
they know they're not that like 100 like
you know Phil can come out there you
know look what's in my right hand and
then and then you know PlayStation's
like we good we good then he then he
stabs him with his left oh no we got a
[__] we got a [__]
so now it looks like that's not probable
uh the biggest thing I think that you
know when it comes to
cloud computing they knew they were
going that way for the longest time I
don't think anything cloud computing
wise really surprised my uh really
surprised PlayStation in terms of this I
think the games is what's going to hurt
them the most because now as far as
bethesda's side
they got an ideal what they're coming
out with they got an idea of what they
can develop to combat these okay you
know this game we can give this a little
bit more time obviously there's still
some question marks but I'm sure
PlayStation knows an ideal of stuff we
don't know that's in in the pipeline
because obviously they got you know they
got friends talking they got um you know
the dev kits at some of these Studios
you know what's the other side of the
building working on uh so I that's the
sap that's the part that sad the most
it's like you know
and I'm sure there's some some Microsoft
Executives watching this and it's like
man I hate it I do I do it's like uh
because it's just like
I hate it as as a consumer and I hate it
as a fan of some of my friends right uh
as a fan of Microsoft I hated it as like
you know I got friends that that work at
Microsoft but as a content creator I'm
like
tomorrow the next day this is new
probably next week's good too yeah like
we we are phenomenal on this but it's
just like you know
I like
the games because they're saying there
we'll get to that here in a second what
games you saw they got they got that
Fallout 3 remake
Libyan remake happened I'm gonna be
partying you know what's crazy it's like
they chose the the most popular games of
those franchises like we bring them back
yeah yeah and and then in the same
documents
it just come out openly said oh Elder
Scrolls six yeah that's ours
this shows that
when they bought them
they knew what they were getting yeah
and you know as far as games being
pushed back I do think there's a chance
that
early infrastructure well you know how
this is just because they expected to
have a doom uh a doom prequel game
doesn't mean that's what happened after
they formally bought the company maybe
stuff went wrong so they might you know
there's certain things on here I think
might switch around or just not be in
development at all right I've been
taught by multiple people that I trust
that ID is not working on a doom game
okay so you know that might have been
exchanged I hope to God Dishonored 3 is
truly coming out because I would love
that and it would make more sense than
anything else a ghostwire Tokyo too oh
yes for me yeah so it's like it's nice
it's nice because what we're seeing
is there was that couple years where
there's a lot of multi-plat stuff that
didn't really bring value to Xbox in
terms of like exclusivity yeah but now
you're starting to see this massive list
and keep in mind the roadmap for
Microsoft was already masked it was
massive already yeah and now this just
added on to it and to your point addict
you know this is a lot of this is still
in a pre-abk world right without the ABK
integration and the things that you know
was going on there so it's a good point
I I felt for you because I know how much
you care about those games that are look
like they're coming so for you you've
always been the guy that we talked
mid-gen refresh you'd be like yeah
that's nice but what's what's the games
that's coming right so to see the games
that you love
see beloved games like especially the
dishonor 3 I was like yeah that's that's
that's that's crazy I've been uh
screaming for dishonor you know we got
what's crazy is 2024 with the i i okay
first off push everything in this list
back a year right that's my personal
opinion I if you expect some of these
games to be out in 2023 2024 I don't
don't think that's realistic like Elder
Scrolls 6 says 2024 yeah this is old
that's not happening that's a different
list that's pre-covered yeah yeah so uh
I would expect some of these games like
you know Dishonored that could probably
come out 2025 early 2025 I would expect
something like that because that's not
that's not really
car wow yeah I'm curious how they do
that you know uh Fallout 3 remaster I
could see that coming out 2024 because
if they don't do a full-blown remake
right it will be easier to get that out
the door and they got the movie in
conjunction with the Fallout movies
coming I know if y'all saw like the um
TV show whatever look really good it
looked really good and what's crazy is
oblivion
remaster was supposed to come out last
year yeah before the pandemic yeah well
what happens if if like it's announced
like the Video Game Awards it's just so
much possibility because because this
Oblivion remaster by the time it should
be at the end
you you would you would expect that
because it was supposed to come out 2022
it's 2023 unless it was canceled which I
don't know if it was or not it's like I
said all these are this was old
information that that was that was
relived
um so any of these could change you know
project castrillo whatever that's called
so many projects yeah we got project
code names that we still don't know what
some of these things are so there's
still more games that we just don't know
and did you notice the 2024 was a
license IEP and again what is that this
is Jess
like we're not even talking about the
rest the Xbox games you're like this is
just them like they had a lot cooking is
is it and it could really show that you
know
Bethesda was worth that purchase it was
worth that much
yeah
you know they out here moving consoles
show up you know what it is
we come in with a trophy and the fact
that they projected Indiana Jones to
come out probably the holiday of last
year makes me think that might be a 2024
game that was supposed to come out with
the movie it makes me think that that
actually might come out holiday of next
year or maybe maybe summer of next year
like like this list just it just adds on
to an already huge massive list like
it's gotten to the point where they're
not discussing what they're gonna do for
games they're discussing when these
games are coming out no I got Gears
Gears of War 6 will be ready 2025. I got
like six games this quarter that's 20
27. yeah we know that this fill
statement is out we're going to get that
for the last topic we just want to talk
about we see I don't thank you we got
y'all we got you but um it just
they are definitely
most well 100
there's probably games right now that's
either done or almost done but they have
no clue when a launch it's like what
we're going to do launch it uh beginning
of next year they're probably going to
get hit with hellblade or vowed middle
of next year probably the other one the
end of next year probably uh Indiana
Jones okay we're going to go into 2025
okay probably Fable out of work too this
do start to get scary if they if they
can Pacquiao it's gonna get to the point
where they're gonna unless they want
these games to come out and I have to
wait six months because they're gonna
have to start letting them catalyze
other Xbox games because it's just like
there's realistically
right now
realistically
there is no way 100 no way in hell
PlayStation keep up quality again this
is a lot of games coming out yeah yeah
like the PlayStation hasn't showed
anything all already really yeah you
know those two shows terrible besides
Spider-Man and Wolverine we know a ghost
we didn't see nothing of Wolverine that
could be canceled
stop it
stop it stop it no one isn't gonna deny
the amount of share volume quality that
these games are gonna be out you know
Spider-Man's gonna come out probably get
a 90 plus that's what I'd expect it to
get it could be 39 they still don't buy
over there it's gonna it's gonna be
highly received the next Naughty Dog
game is going to be highly received and
they're going to do well they're gonna
and then Microsoft's gonna walk in the
back door with 585 plus games and knock
that dude out
the sheer volume will overwhelm them but
they do got to be quality y'all they do
got to be quality volume is one thing I
mean start Fielding shows right no
absolutely now again if we're if we're
talking from a star field quality and
that type of zeitgeist
you know people like to make fun of Xbox
got no but besides breath fall what
unquality games do they have it's a
massive EFX box waistline three 85 Plus
um
The Age of Empires 85 Plus 80 plus right
you got the cycle knocks it's like an 86
87 like literally they are doing nothing
but hitting hits out now they need
Blockbuster Now call to selling games on
top of that yeah because I feel like
they do have a lot of you know uh
smaller titles that right nothing wrong
with that and I feel like a lot of
people love those because I love
Wasteland three it was a phenomenal game
but you do need those particular games
that gravitate people towards them the
nice looking game I think I think I
think you're gonna get that with like
Fable perfect dark hopefully I don't
know my favorite looks amazing uh you're
gonna get that with the next gears
because gears always looks great I think
you're gonna probably get that with a
lot of uh you know not to mention we
don't know what's going to happen with
the uh with Oblivion and Fallout 3
when I see Legacy I think of games
that's already out on platforms yeah
most likely these are these are going to
be on Playstation but that that game
pass day and day it's like oh man you go
buy that game I'm gonna play over here
where I don't have to invest that much I
think you're right and I think you honor
something and I think that's the better
strategy
um which one no the strategy that he
just said yeah the Legacy titles those
titles are remastered the remakes or
whatever
yeah day and Dayton Game Pass and let
let these dudes over here pay the cash
for the finance house
and go play with that and just bring me
back my money go go go let's go
PlayStation has nothing to worry about
you're seeing PlayStations move say that
they're worrying about it they're
they're scooping up all these Studios
they're trying to put stuff on PC you
know they're doing whatever they can and
with the bank account that they have
available to them to combat Microsoft's
big big bank account it's truth though
like you know if right now play State
you guys can say what you want in the
chat on the piano Dollar General and
Playstation could buy the studios that
Microsoft is buying they would have done
it by now and what's funny is they
always say you know people always say uh
what's that what's that nice little
sentence that they love saying called
organic growth organic growth acting
like PlayStation wasn't on the Bethesda
purchase they got out purchased by
Microsoft like they didn't try to buy
the people that um
yeah we've already established it the
last five the last five Studio purchases
were not organic they were they had no
prior relationship with I'm sorry so I'm
glad you jumping in
no no yeah you're absolutely right and
we we haven't talked about the numbers
that came out about uh prices that
Microsoft was willing to pay to put
certain things yo you see them game pass
prices
I mean obviously some of that stuff
hasn't come to fruition right
it really is we're gonna drown you you
can't you cannot follow us into these
Waters it's impossible
p is out right now
where's that where's that at kick yeah
that's on Game Pass right now lives of
people hey hey we eating good over here
when the leaks come out lots of pressure
I gotta ask off this like so what did
you think you such a red dead guy did
you see the drink where they respected
the Red Dead remastered bro the price
was crazy
it was like yeah okay let me read the
book before you read the list
um solve but did you see in 2022 where
they had the drought right
before they knew Phil made the statement
like yo this is a you know back then we
we got we have to Double Down based on
what has now happened before the news
gets out but Red Dead was supposed they
was counting on that remaster and to get
that into Game Pass in that year as well
I just wanted to know what you thought
of that before okay I mean again it goes
to show that like covert messed
everything up and put pushed everything
back a year year and a half because
again at this point we thought that a
Red Dead next gen wasn't happening
because it's like all right you're gonna
give us this redneck one sort of uh Port
right you're not even doing it and then
people running around on Console 30 FPS
and read that too wondering where is
this 60fps upgrade
um and the Assumption was well it's not
going to be a patch it's going to be a
new SKU it's going to be the next gen
version but again with all hands on deck
for GTA 6 we're like all right they're
not doing it then they're just skipping
over it and whatever if you want to play
60fps go to the PC yeah um but yeah I
mean that was again that was surprising
that that was there and the price was
these projections
what's these projections so we got Jedi
Survival how much they want a 300
million dollars hey Star Wars Buddy
Red Dead Redemption 2 it looked like 5
million per month I think oh they got a
different rate don't take it shout out
to drugs out here doing the words he's
like now our rate is per month King
and it's good because we ain't gonna
keep me in that long we're just gonna
keep you in there a good time yo he got
a purple
we do we're gonna do five million per
month we're gonna give you the
300.00 take two is outside ready yeah
yeah 25 million good we got you for five
months going again
homie then you got Suicide Squad for 250
million dig ahead with that Mortal
Kombat one for 250 million yeah you know
Assassin's Creed
Rifts
we got uh Gotham Knights for 30 million
yeah
dying like two for 15. Xbox
we got Dying Light too for 50 million
okay we got Lego Star Wars for 30
minutes 35 million and they outside I
guess those would be moving yeah oh no
the Star Wars was extreme
Star Wars yeah
Dragon Ball the breaker was 20 million
okay we had GTA 5 between 12 to 15
million per month yo what's up what
happened to her love bro yo when I hear
attic doing this you know what I hear
damn it the hell with these marketing
Tails we're gonna get these games done
you talk about it you can come over here
and play them though facts fact then we
got wreck Fest two for 10 to 14 million
return to Monkey Island for five million
yeah no this is the one that this is the
one that got a lot of uh publicity it
was Baldur's Gate three four five yeah
see here's the thing that I think the
reason that they were quoted five
million is because this was this was a
long time ago
it was in preview at the time so these
were the projections so they had the
five million because they looked at
Boulders gay and they said oh yeah
that's a stadium
people say well Microsoft underestimated
Bulger first off who didn't yeah it was
a lot who did it yeah and second off
and second off if you're Microsoft and
you're looking at a uh you know a
preview build of a game that's on Steam
that you could probably port to PC
pretty easily or port to Xbox to be in
the preview program and give them money
to put on Game Pass why would you give
them premium money for a game that's not
finished and released tell the truth
Shane the Devil Without It Anyway
I gotta get Kingston
hit that like button this is emergency
though
you don't rock on a Tuesday we're in
your mouth
Just Dance for five million blood
Runners for 5 million and glitch Busters
for five
that's part of the package that's part
of the package
all right so we got this so we go with
the list add it cause I gotta get kicked
all right we got a butt a bus load of
super chats it's great yeah we're gonna
get two we're gonna get to it look we
got it we got to get to this so kick
like I guess my question is for you
there's two things obviously you take it
as far as what leaks you want to talk
about the first but I do want to ask you
see that Sunday called Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah
Tuesday energy when he was talking to
solver yeah I'm warm it up emergency
podcast you know what I'm saying so like
my day with you is like
the religion refresh right but also I
really want to get into the weeds with
the the next gen console because we're
here in this this hybrid such thing
right where it's like you know cohesive
hybrid compute our vision develop a Next
Generation hybrid game platform capable
of leveraging the combined power of the
client and the cloud to deliver deeper
immersion and new classes of game
experience experiences optimized for
real-time gameplay and creators we will
enable new levels of performance beyond
the capabilities of the client Hardware
alone they're talking about
using arm 64 versus traditional x64 Zen
right a balance of big and uh little CPU
cores I'm not going to get into the
weeds with the machine learning and
that's that's all for territory we can
go there but Graphics innovation
rate uh next gen direct x-ray tracing
Global illumination super resolution so
where are you at with all the links but
I do want to get your thought on the
consoles now you're a hardware guy so
mid-gen refresh not doing a pro and then
the the 2028 vision of this next
generation of Xbox where do you sit with
all this okay first first I want to say
this I mean I know y'all see me really
giddy
um this really affects a lot of people
right so I'm going to say first and
foremost to all my friends
Microsoft and everybody else that you
know on the periphery of this you know
developers and stuff that people that
had their games talked about that they
weren't ready to reveal all of those
things
um I do apologize for how you feel right
now because yeah you know I'm part of
the problem at this moment right at this
moment right now we're talking about it
we're going to perpetuate it but
as a provocateur
I'm gonna defend the hell out of this
right because you know everything isn't
always as bad as it as it seems and
everything isn't always as good as good
as it looks all right so we're at a
point right now where all the stuff came
out and everybody's like oh oh it's bad
it's bad it's bad it's bad but it on the
surface it looks good too right so you
got to take the good with the bad you
got to take the Ying with the gang now
to the hardware let's get it first I
thought we wasn't getting Hardware
um no all these dudes out here running
just the other day somebody was quoting
me out of their head like don't call me
because I'll show up and when I show up
I show paperwork all right so I show it
with paperwork I don't see nobody
talking and real quick King you know
this is massive leaks that that's very
disappointing but in terms of like
besides the games like they really just
said a bunch of stuff that's been leaked
at one point in time like I don't think
they're like obviously the leaks suck
but when you look at like leak for leak
we've heard some form of rumor going
towards that you know Phil's saying
there's not going to be midgen refresh
we clearly expect them still to have a
slim of some sort no but to see the
thing with that is
when he said listen everybody doesn't
want to believe that this Hardware
generation has been stunted
it's stunted all right your PlayStation
has not lived up to its potential
okay really get a grip on that
understand that part
it has not
the Xbox hasn't at all there's still
room to breathe in both of these
consoles and a lot of y'all thinking oh
they did they're not doing 60 frames or
they're stuttering and inside the third
I really believe that's has a
a product of crunch
um and how they had to develop these
games at a distance right
when they get back to traditional and
we heard a lot of our friends talk about
the getting people back to the office
practices of old of being in the same
building getting people to come to work
getting getting stuff done right
everybody gets into these bad new habits
of uh doing it social distancing and a
lot of work who's in the game and
sending the game in that's why you get
leaks and stuff like this because no
longer is somebody taking a paperwork
over to the courthouse somebody is
uploading a file to the wrong spot this
is the stuff that is happening now this
is why we got more leaks than ever this
is why this stuff is wildest as it's
ever been yeah it's because it's no more
person-to-person stuff so we're getting
everything pushed back now I truly
expect it and I told y'all on the show
that yeah Phil's going to come out next
year E3 and he gonna beat him upside
their head again like he they did the
last time and they're gonna announce the
pro and they gonna announce the console
anyway like yeah so what right we got
this too now everybody's gonna say but
but King it's not gonna go take over the
power they catching up to power
we ain't got to go past why do we gotta
go past anything
okay all right so questions catch up to
power but pricing yes on this is gonna
be different okay all right so the
PlayStation come out seven hundred
dollars so you say it's seven no I think
it's gonna be like uh 6.99 the rumors
were five it could be Hey listen it
could be I was wrong before okay okay
not necessarily gonna be wrong but my
thing but they couldn't they could also
get it
chase people on the box
right four to be that five they're gonna
sheist you on the box what you mean it's
like the portal I thought the portal was
gonna be a real handheld right
well because it's not a real handheld
okay it's it's a screen technically it
can do things but it don't do things you
understand what I'm saying okay so I
think they can make that price what we
do know
Microsoft will make the the parts and
stuff and more efficient they will add a
little quality of life like already
confirmed already yeah you know two
terabits of uh because the games are
getting larger in downloads now you know
I was just downloading Eliza P right now
so I and I saw that it was crazy but at
the same time we need more space
a nice uh if you didn't like the square
uh series X or this you know got a nice
cylinder
looking no disc type of thing no disc no
disk you're good no no I believe I
believe that they'll probably sell a
disk drive on the side the same okay the
pregnant uh Playstation where you could
buy the uh the baby holder on the side
yeah the same thing you know it's
question I know I'm interrupted I
apologize
I'm sorry
um I just I just want a scenario if you
see if they if PlayStation 5 Pro is
ruined by Tom Henderson to be at that
500 point at that same holiday season
that Microsoft was we clearly know was
going to surprise them so my question is
can so you think they will drop the four
because okay okay because my thing is
they can't be five at the same as these
guys being five with a more powerful
system they're gonna be cheaper okay
they're gonna beat them cheaper with
more games like you are the priciest for
no reason you you are pricey how bad do
they want to play Spider-Man like how
bad do they want to play well we haven't
seen Wolverine how bad do they want to
play the the CGI Wolverine uh clip again
you know how bad do you want to do it do
you want to do a 600 bad or do you want
to play a game and I feel that
it has shown right it has shown those
dudes that brought those PlayStations
y'all are here y'all already here y'all
ain't going anyplace y'all already got a
PlayStation I think it's gonna start
winding down now you know after
Spider-Man comes out they're gonna get
the last couple of stragglers in because
I see them things sitting in the store
shelves they did you know hey go in
there pick up a Playstation all right
cool it's a great thing for y'all but
it's gonna start winding out because the
games are going to start overwhelming
you now it's more about the hard way in
the games in conjunction okay so you you
don't have to do a mid-gen refresh when
you start churning out the games let the
game speak for them sell the hardware
that you do have let that Hardware fly
off the shelves with all the quality
games that you do put out and then let
the game speak for itself let Game Pass
be that vehicle that you said it was and
I'm gonna give a shout out to my man
Phil Dominus Maxim it's a really
expensive living to every last word of
his name
dude is the boss that I told you he was
everybody said that oh now he's nice
he's kissing babies hugging people and
shaking hands
yes you do do that that's part of the
job yes you do do that but at the same
time is it equally exclusive that he
wants to take over no
that's one person that can be married
and that ambition is baked into that
person he can have compassion for you
all he wants but at the end of the day
sometimes you gotta put a knife in you a
little bit that ambition is real hustle
is ambition it gotta be that way I'm
sorry Tony
I'm sorry oh man I'm like Daddy Tony you
was my best worker
because
people do with the smile but he said
look what you made me do to you
all you had to do was take the offer but
King he what about Nintendo yeah but
Nintendo need them am I not My Brother's
Keeper
am I not My Brother's Keeper so so but
but okay you know the pushback is gonna
be this is the problem world domination
the Monopoly the dishes they gonna say
that they're gonna say evil with me B
don't block me PlayStation been teasing
me for a long time don't choose me bro
we at the point right now
it's yo I'm so happy I woke up and
sorted
I'm so happy I woke up and saw this
cause you know we ain't playing no more
like yo before I had to be humble with
y'all walk past y'all knowing that I was
gonna beat y'all up no one else is gonna
set it on you but now you know I came in
school I was doing this to you three
o'clock three o'clock so three o'clock
hit is a rap this is the three o'clock
document yeah it's a time now so they
all thought Starfield was just a one-off
yeah I really saw because y'all had hope
but Elder Scrolls six though because
that's a legacy wait a second
wait a second yeah this is the part of
the game I told you ain't gonna be no
PlayStation six and y'all thought I
wasn't playing it you standing there you
standing down in the building
okay so his shooter tell you we'll spend
them out of business
nah Phil we're gonna keep this game pass
and we're gonna keep day and date and
we're gonna spin them out of business
see because they don't got money like us
why you gotta have to see it he sounds
like Jim Carrey right now he hit me with
the Al Capone see yeah see this is a
team game you see and if they don't want
to play the game
this is why the government gonna get
involved because they're involved right
now I mean they ain't doing things right
because what happened they get involved
stuff get leaked out obviously the
government got a little bit of issues
they need to tighten up over here but
you can't stop progress baby like his
ambition is so crazy he looked over with
the house that Mario built and said I
like you and I want
when they come to that realization
they're wearing the right thing for you
you me that didn't sound like the dude
that said yeah I'ma marry her yes like
he talking to you he was like she don't
know right now that I'm the man I'm
gonna marry her
she gonna be mine and she's gonna love
it
Philly ambition is crazy I get for it I
love his ambition right because you have
not seen ambition like this like first
of all you're seeing Cowboys when the
last time you seen Jimmy he just had a
show he sent somebody else out there he
sent out a whole different person
somebody we've never seen before yeah
thank you for showing up to the police
this is what it is okay keep talking
boss moves
all you saw was paperwork of Boss movies
y'all fearful of the boss man y'all keep
saying y'all want Xbox to compete
paperwork keep coming out
he out there punching people in the back
of the heads grabbing people up in
Corners telling them you know it's gonna
work it just don't work
and your best friend now is gonna be
crossing the street like yo Xbox got the
game man
what you going to do you're gonna look
at your PlayStation and say
you had a good run I can't you had a
good run but these do I'm sorry I'm
sorry I gotta trade you in I got to get
the new redesign to redesign the
circular you got a little bit more yeah
six that's the controller
the control I gotta talk about the
control let's talk about it all right so
there's little aspects in the controller
that tells you where they're going
first when you see The Branding on the
logo no cons so needed yes
remember that
that's how you reach everybody else
the controller why would the controller
have a wake up
wake up on touch yeah why because it's
going to identify with you and then it
also can
I'm linked to your phone link to your
tablet link to your TV
why is this controller important why
does it have better haptic why does it
have gyroscope yep why is all this why
does it have a speaker it's all these
things that's inside the controller
because the controller is going to be
the de facto at a point in time that
controller is going to be your Xbox
because that's going to be your portal
into your gameplay
that's the direct link to the next
console so y'all sitting there saying oh
but they're going to be using arm and
arm is a smaller chip and the chip is
more flexible and they're talking about
artificial intelligence who owns chat
gbt wake up
wake up
you see where things are going they're
telling you that they're pushing stuff
to the cloud the crowd is the
infrastructure is there they are all
over they have structures all over the
place so now it's going to be at the
point where that cloud is a reality we
do see it offloading things but with the
uh ability to have uh AI navigate that
whole thing and tie the threads to that
why you think they're funneling so much
money into AI so allow these things to
actually become a reality so yeah 2028
is really far away factual right so it's
far away technologically because we're
going to have to grow Leaps and Bounds
to research but those mild steps are
being made right and if any indicator is
that controller that controller is going
to tell you the road map you're going to
have a piece of the future by the time
that controller comes out you're already
going to have a foot into the Next
Generation because that that's exactly
where they're going to take you so I
told you before Game Pass was the
vehicle I told you again to reach those
when somebody tells you they want to
reach 8 billion people and you laugh at
them you're laughing at somebody with
true ambition yeah
just crazy exactly so if somebody tells
you they can see eight billion people
you got to reverse engineer how do you
see those eight billion people what are
you talking about you have to break down
the conversation and once he starts to
tell you how he's going to achieve this
stuff is a reason why Satya looked over
at him and said okay you got the money
go do what you got to do reason why
because if you can see it you can
achieve it and you can make it happen
and he's on the road to doing that what
happens if Nintendo does take him
serious and say you know what I see what
you're doing with this stuff over here
and I do like exactly where you're going
uh all we want to do is just have
control and ownership over this
and they allowed it to happen what
happens then when you when you tell
Nintendo
don't worry about the Hardwell aspect
just worry about software yeah
and we will build the hardware to your
specifications I mean if that seem like
some sort of a proposal right as far as
you know their realization I don't know
if let you finish it I'm done because as
a provocateur
this has given me the ammo
for a lot of these little naysayers that
Xbox oh if Game Pass doesn't reach uh a
certain number there's gonna be a point
facts I heard you our soul I brought
paperwork paperwork say they they are
super committed to console they yeah
don't pay that article any mind when I'm
telling you you're talking for no reason
you're just talking for the clicks and
the likes and to be heard and understand
what you're trying to do and it's a good
thing what I want you to do is be
mindful of your words because if my name
is in your mouth
say it three times I'll pop up with
paperwork
I changed the way you look now you
looking clownish you're looking foolish
I haven't seen you in two days I would
like for you to show back up but
remember I always tell you if you're
gonna clip something clip the whole
thing a little part and make a marriage
and make a little story to get your
little views up and get people to no I
got more viewership from you behave
yourself I got more people following me
because of you you highlighting me you
how you gonna try to make me look stupid
but making yourself look stupid by
proving my point
[Music]
I love you I love you with all my heart
but I'm gonna tell you I'm the wrong
person to mess with I love this Twitter
stuff I know you love beef stop it yes
love beef way too much pause pause on
that anyway let me get my balls up this
man out here
we outside baby out here Twitter
shooting all right now relax yourself
but
anyway look man wow this is this what's
up man this was this was crazy what
about you switching to me Bubble switch
to me because they don't want you don't
want to switch to beat right now but
anyway I'll figure we'll figure it out
but look you know double click your
screen yeah I did I don't know it was
just it's just on some some Winans you
don't want you don't want to let me live
yeah okay there you go anyway so um look
this is first of all I want to repeat
what king said and um all seriousness
you know as as content creators
obviously yes we we love getting
information we love knowing about this
kind of stuff and you know I think
there's one thing to
there's one thing to have like a rumor
and say okay for next year or the next
quarter you know this is gonna happen
right and that's par for the course that
we've seen that kind of stuff leaks are
inevitable it's gonna happen but I will
say this one did bother me
because it's one thing to leak and then
there's another thing to have your
entire road map stuff that you can tell
is authentic documents from The
Boardroom right and to to King's Point
we know there are tons of people who
work hours upon hours to get this
information and to have it presented
with proper context right to have it
presented in a way that we fully
understand the vision because let's be
clear what we're seeing right now yeah
we have an understanding but we don't
know what you know a vision of a hybrid
console could be without actual proof of
concept right we don't know a lot of
what this stuff is without the
visualization and seeing stuff in it so
that's the part that I really have a lot
of empathy and sympathy for the teams
because they this was not under their
control and now people could just go
wherever with the narrative right and
and not truly fully understand the
vision so that's unfortunate and and
it's a shame so I do feel for them in
that respect as a content creator
obviously we have to talk about it I
didn't like it you know what I'm saying
like so we have to talk about it so look
for me
let's start with the refresh
um
I was surprised obviously you know they
they surprised us last time with you
know little little black man King right
they they surprised us right we didn't
see that coming so this would have been
another one we didn't see coming so to
your point it would have been a counter
punch in a way not that it was more
powerful than the PlayStation 5 Pro but
the reality is they would have had an
answer to say hey we have our Hardware
coming out I do agree with you I do I do
feel though that price wise if we do
find out that the PlayStation 5 Pro is
500 there's no way I feel they could
come out at 500 with the system right
they're gonna have to do something or
they may internally know that it may not
be 500 for them so they may be safe and
keep it but the thing is this and
it would have been a preemptive strike
right just like the last one you
remember they struck first right and
then then you forced them to follow suit
you for you you put price and make them
either drop their price to get close
enough to your price and make them drown
or you set a prices close enough to
their price I I think they can take a
little loss on the hardware because
they're going to have so much software
and they want to sell you so much
subscriptions that they take the loss on
the hardware yeah no it's possible it's
very possible and um you know the
reality is obviously with with the ABK
deal and all like attic was saying
perfectly which is that you know we see
the vision based on what we saw in 2021
and obviously what we see this year
right 2022 was definitely the banana
peel slip and that didn't you know
wasn't part of the division he actually
caught they actually commented about
that where they talked about how like
you know we really have to dig down hard
based on what we know now with Starfield
and and this stuff not coming out so um
yeah it's it's it's it's it's really
interesting to see that part so that's
the that's the hardware part obviously
the revision the cylinder everything
looks cool you know not surprising at
least I love Wi-Fi six I love the
control I love what they're doing now
the distance thing does not bother me
I've already resigned my myself to the
fact that if you're going to have a
digital future and you're going to have
Game Pass as the driver that's where
it's going to go so for the reality
again I know my physical Hardware you
know Lords and Ladies I some people are
not about that I've already in my mind
when they've we've come up with Gamepad
this is division that's where it's going
right whether or not you know you choose
to stay there because of that is is a
personal thing so you got that you know
but that's the thing wow I feel crazy
baffled up like their whole business was
out like every aspect of what's going on
but you know obviously the creator of me
loves me some Dishonored three loves
that Oblivion is coming like based on
what we saw from Bethesda they are
proving they're worth tenfold with that
acquisition if everything comes to
fruition the Indiana Jones all the
project games you see what starfield's
doing now it's like you know it's a big
deal it's a big deal that they're gonna
have that Cadence consistent we're not
even talking about the rest of Xbox game
studios yet we just talk about them just
them so in this is in a pre
-abk World crazy so we got that you know
I do want to comment on
the hybrid console because I do see a
lot of pushback and a lot of people are
saying King like yo
that's not a future I want a part of to
solves point you know they make comments
like bro we just been through this with
Crackdown when y'all gonna learn y'all
lessons leave that cloud alone then the
other pushback is we did see in some of
the documents that
they there was a statement kind of
challenging feel from another Microsoft
exec and I forgot the the lady's name
where they were like look we understand
the vision
but I'm worried that you're building a
moat right you know what a moat is right
around a castle and you know from the
content side we're going to try to
adjust and pivot but almost like we're
not sure we're hoping that this cloud is
the way right to go that is going to
coincide with the with the game and the
content delivery and you know I think
Phil did make a comment about
um you know what do you think would have
happened you know without Game Pass or
something to that effect right just
trying to get legit feedback as to why
this exact was a little nervous right
and what we have seen is a pullback from
cloud on some of these documents right
so the question some people are having
King is saying okay if you're gonna pull
back from cloud almost God admitting it
was a mistake but admitting that you
didn't have to go as hard right but then
in 2028 allegedly right where you're
going to have a hybrid console why are
you committing to a hybrid console with
Cloud involved on any level so this is
what I'm going to say and I think it's a
valid argument
my thing is this
2023 Cog right now says yeah that does
seem a bit strange right but 2028 Cog we
don't know where the industry is going
to go we don't know what these proof of
concepts are and one thing I will say as
Gamers sometimes we are
we can't see it right so it's like it to
me it reminds me of
Xbox's Inception if you would have told
me yo bro there's gonna be we out here
playing with Nintendo yeah like like we
out here playing with Gamecube and I say
attic yo bro I'm gonna make a console
and what we're gonna do is we all gonna
have FiOS Internet we're gonna have to
fast and then we're gonna be able to
talk to each other online play again and
you like bro x-band ain't even out like
I said like we're using dial-up what
future are you talking about right and
they're like nah I'm telling you this is
what we're gonna be able to do we're
gonna do extra we're gonna have a party
chat we're gonna be able to play between
each other's game and you're gonna like
yeah bro that sound nice but you know
what I'm saying it is the same thing
like yo bro it's going to be digital
games
and you know you ain't gonna have to go
to the midnight launch no more and
you're gonna be able to download
pre-order at your house and we like yeah
that sound like again right and then I'm
gonna tell you like yo bro like it ain't
gonna be no more um Netflix and all that
you're gonna be able to download the app
to your 360 and you're gonna do all your
music you're gonna watch TV from your
console
right think about it think about telling
us back then that all this gonna happen
and we gonna sit there and go get it so
again
I'm trying to reserve judgment because
we have information without context we
have information without proof of
content they even say like some of this
stuff is still some stuff they do have
you know as far as their XBox
um structure and then other things they
like yo we got something so let's just
say in 2028 which is substantial time
from now that is five years from now and
you're gonna tell me like that's like me
telling you yo bro we ain't gonna use
gas no more we're gonna have electric
cars and you're like shut up shut up I'm
gonna be like bro shut up 23 23 cars
gonna look at you stupid right but again
I'm not privy to 2028 [__] I'm not privy
to all the things that they you know
that things that that technology could
marriage and and close gaps so it's
going to be the sad part about this leak
is it's going to be more imperative for
them to have those proof of Concepts to
show boom this is the wave this is what
we're doing you know what I'm saying and
the last
remember a lot of times we got to give
Xbox this they are the first to innovate
always sometimes it's just a little too
early right because think about this and
now it's my final point I give it to you
try to go all digital and look what
happened right but it ended up happening
anyway and then think about the Xbox One
Xbox One generation for a second and
remember how disgusted people were
bro TV they marrying games with TV
nobody's doing TV show games what are
you doing what is happening now with the
Witcher cyberpunk Edge runners
what is happening now right oh all of
the things that we said are stupid don't
make sense it's not the future of are
literally happening and are now feeding
Last of Us is on HBO moving and shaking
and is now feeding the games industry
so again I understand the fear of the
future I'm scared too I don't know how
things gonna play out because I don't
have proof of concept but when you look
at 2023 and then 2028 they have a vision
so in my opinion let's just wait pump
the brakes before we say it's not fair
mongering and see where Tech goes that's
all I gotta say but other than that look
you know I again I feel for the teams I
I know they wanted to do things on their
own you know Accord and I do want to
switch gears to topic two I'm sorry I'm
sorry I don't have to shoot you go ahead
I think
when it comes to the cloud computer
thing I do think if they're if they're
planning on revolving the entire console
around that that's that's an issue but
right if they're planning even if it's
one of those things where it's like we
don't know what's in five years it's
like I could definitely switch that way
or it could not go that way right I I I
don't even think Microsoft knows but
then it's going to be in five years so
right it's like you know I I feel like
you the cloud computing needs to be an
option yeah and as long as they build
the system as it as that an option I
don't think there'll be too much of an
issue but if I would say it's like I
said the only issue I would see is if
they're trying to build this thing only
Cloud right because like 80 Cloud 20 not
Cloud that's where I would be announced
they have a couple like like massive
multiplayers that they use in the cloud
infrastructure to to generate them
that's that's okay but it's like do not
Center the entire cloud computing right
around this system make sure it does
what it's supposed to first but if you
want you could play Everything Cloud you
don't have to download nothing because I
think that's what they're doing they're
like look we're gonna give you an Xbox
two or whatever they're gonna call it
and and you can play everything like you
do now or
with our new cloud computing technology
that we've came out the last five years
you can play Everything where it feels
natively on the cloud you don't ever
have to download anything and as long as
it's like a decision that and then you
know they prove proof of concept once
you prove to people that it works and
it's efficient it works consistently
then you can start dialing the other
stuff back but you have to have that
proof of concept into me do not do the
proof of concept at the launch right I
mean look it's one of those things that
that's going to be on them to have to to
prove to people and I do think you got a
good point in reference to
um you know how it's integrated because
again as Gamers all we think about is
Crackdown when they you know when you
know oh man they better not be that and
everybody not talking about they gonna
get extra teraflops off the cloud
because I I right so the way I look at
it is again I have to just look at the
document and what I can see
and it says they're leveraging the
combined power of the cloud cloud to
deliver deep immersion and new class of
game experiences right so part of me
also thinks there's also things on the
back end that put it this way can you
remember this one of the downfalls that
even though you were clowning what we
used to call them Phil luminous
yeah red shoes red shoes right so
where's the client remember when he came
out with the stadia announcement mm-hmm
and if you remember there was a
statement where remember addict they
were like yo we're integrating YouTube
into it and then when you're playing
your game your favorite streamer could
come in remember all those features that
never came out that like stadiums
features from a cloud perspective was
fire they went back to the drug they
went back and was like yeah okay I said
all this but we never agreed to none of
that like bro none of that figure it out
like but it's not possible none of that
stuff came out but at the time right we
were like yo if they Implement that
that's actually fine y'all did that yeah
I did I did listen
I believe nothing he said because I knew
where we were but what I'm saying is so
now if there's some type of machine
learning there's some type of back end
experience that makes keeping case in
point okay last point I'll say
we got these series X's I don't know
about you but I don't remember a time
where you grab your phone
and you set up your console remember
that was the greatest thing I've ever
done okay so again subtle ways of
implementation of cloud and things that
made the experience better this is this
okay
you're you're definitely on fire with
that okay
but this is Microsoft we're talking
about facts
okay we're talking about a software
company yes that was all done through
software yes right so the ability to
have that conversation from your phone
to your console to your Wi-Fi to
everything right made it so simple and
so easy yes
they have the engineers on they end that
I honestly believe see this is why I
didn't believe Phil luminous
at first I don't trust you that's one
the red boots I did I was just like nah
nah he's wrong
the stuff that he was adding on to it
right like like addict says proof of
concept don't show up that day and don't
talk about the moon right but we're
coming out this week we're coming out
this week and we don't have the the
YouTuber jumping feature ready but down
the line we would but we just need more
people to invest in us I don't want that
energy and I don't Microsoft don't give
me that energy yeah Microsoft is going
to get you to point A to point we just
happened to see the the robe uh yeah the
photo back
but the next console if they say that
it's going to be powered by X Y and Z
and they're telling you that they're
going to use the arm chip that means
they have the thought process in it to
be flexible yes flexibility of that chip
to take it from the archaic you know I
was looking to oh Noah's Alex right and
I looked at him in caseante for my PC
knowledge
and
the way that they talk about the
consoles yeah it's like they're low end
off the shelf
86 whatever it is called the motherboard
they they they act like our consoles
aren't what we believe them to be right
now if these guys think that could you
imagine what the engineers that are
putting it together and they are
futurists right and they're looking at
the tech going forward they have to
Future proof whatever the tech is and
they have to think years ahead facts
I believe the last part I'm saying then
I'll move on because I want to give
Atticus flowers with this one is that
you know I see another a lot of pushback
on the fact that they're not doing a
true Xbox One X style upgrade
and I get it I get it and I listen we're
so used to let's be honest right the
digital Foundry comparisons right and
and you get in the third party the
multi-plat and I'll say this the the
reason why listen I'm all about the
power I'm not even gonna front I do like
that right that's my joint I like you
know listen I'm I'm the guy that's gonna
pick up this console but it would have
picked up a console that gives more
frames and Ray tracing or whatever but I
want to say this
we got to be real too and this is for
the Xbox community
for all the flops and all the resolution
and don't get me wrong when the 1X
Scorpio propped off we was on digital
Foundry popping bottles off of every
frame and everything that was better on
a third-party game and it was a
beautiful time
but we got to be real too
with Spider-Man
God of War Last of Us came out did
anyone care about them at that point so
the point I'm trying to say is you got
to have the games and attic has been
consistent all the way through and every
time we talk about a new system and a
new thing he'd be like all right that's
cool so what about what what game is
going to be on it that's for them that
you see what I'm saying the difference
is when you have a year like this or the
2023 and you have a star field and you
have a Zeitgeist you have a moment
you're moving consoles you have a high
five rush you have an Asian vampires you
have a Forza Motorsport right and you
have all these things and then you
obviously you had the 2021 and then you
have a you know 2022 which potentially
we just saw all this roadmap and we saw
ABK good deal could close so every game
of Activision Blizzard King in Game Pass
but that's this lineup Xbox now you got
the games bro
right so my point is are you going to
care about GTA having more frames or are
you going to care that hellblade is a 90
Metacritic about is a 90 Metacritic that
all the games that you have are quite
and guess what they're in this amazing
service oh by the way your man who don't
even rock with Xbox because we saw the
splits on Series S and X I don't know if
we saw for that April 70 more people in
that year that time frame
had Xbox series s versus Xbox series X
so what is your it was like your thing
with the the you know you call it the
broker right so you get a Lockhart it's
it's always going to be the software so
if they got the software and that dude
now it's like yo you know what I got a
place you got Nintendo but I could pick
up a series s right now get in the game
pass have what you call it right have um
Call of Duty off rip and all of
Activision what's gonna matter more and
then you yourself can improve this is
not about power exactly and you yourself
King and attic are talking about the
volume
if you got 85s let's just say let's just
go lowball
and not everything's a 90. let's just
say you got nothing but 80 to 85 87s but
they're coming out quarterly every two
and you got the Game Pass fillers in
between the lives of PE
it starts to get crazy
right it starts to be an accumulation by
itself this [__] is showing right now
they're they're eating right now I don't
know what nobody else talking about I
don't pay about attention to social
media they're eating right now as far as
this volume and not I think yeah I
literally don't have enough time to play
everything that's out right now
literally see your stars lies a p all
this stuff is out sitting there running
around in game passes all that stuff so
look that's all I'm saying and I get it
you know what I'm saying with that with
the console stuff I completely get it as
far as that but if you have and then the
last point I said I've always said three
skew approach you've already we already
have the S and the X yeah now you're
gonna tell the developer to make a third
and let's be honest some people are a
little annoyed we got to be honest there
are some chirps of people that don't
that want to do the extra development
time for the series s or whatever based
on their Studio size or what have you
right so yeah we gotta see but anyway
that's all I gotta say
let's move on to the next one this was
the funny one I do have to ask you about
this
so
um
responsibility of the leaks
obviously hold on hold on I got I got
who did it
um
it's awesome let's fix it
what is he doing what's he doing over
there
this is man dumb but yeah look I I while
you were looking for pictures yeah shout
out to video game Chronicle their state
is that Microsoft was a partly
reportedly responsible for this week's
giant Xbox League the documents
revealing confidential plans were
published on a federal court website and
this is from Bloomberg they said that um
signing a person familiar with the
Madame Microsoft accidentally uploaded
the information to the quartz website
and then the FTC office of public
affairs director Douglas farar said that
the emergency wasn't behind the league
the FTC was not responsible for
uploading Microsoft plans and yeah so
that's that's what we got right now
where the FTC has said it
we got it
he just took a flight right now
listen if you don't see solver IOP for
the next couple of months my voice on
the run right now
[Laughter]
they were circling around me
yo what happened at the TSA was you all
right
you're gonna be doing the podcast live
for PR now
what's up bro so let's get you because
we get a chance so FTC claiming that you
know Microsoft did like they they're
trying to say it's it's on it's on the
boys so wait wait where you at with the
blame with the with how did this happen
how did we get here
what's the thing right I mean an FDC
spokesman came out and said like it
wasn't us right so I again I don't know
at some point
you can't do finger pointing for that
some point like the reality of who's
fault this is going to come out so um
you know that that was the early story
right and then it got sort of changed
and it became internally for Microsoft
that they accidentally uploaded it to
the website
um and left it unprotected
um um which is Bonkers to me right so I
don't know I you know again this will
probably be something that fluid and
continues to change and we'll get an
answer a real answer at some point yeah
um but that's that's just wow man it is
so crazy
because the thing is
the thing you know what's crazy about it
though like we talked about Lena Khan a
little bit earlier thank you think about
all the stuff that we just saw in these
documents bro all of this proof that
that Microsoft's goal is to just take
over the game hey and they still
couldn't beat them in court
it is Bonkers that you see this email
where he's like yeah Nintendo's ours
they just don't know it yet
did you guys did you guys see the uh the
article where they're talking about
hostile takeover to Nintendo yo wow it's
really crazy so again it is FTC stuff
again it's Stacy politics and safety
this is the very it's funny you think
well video games
[Music]
what's funny is like I'll read you I'll
read you a uh apart from this article
where it says uh this is this is a uh an
email with Phil Spencer
just read how crazy this sounds I've
kept in touch with uh Mason I I don't
know uh morphett as he's been acquiring
it's likely he'll be pushing for more
from Nintendo stock which we could
create opportunities for us without that
Catalyst I don't see an angle to uh to a
near term mutually agreeable merger of
Nintendo in Microsoft I don't think a
hostile action would be a good move
so we are playing the long game
how is that even how is it that's what
kicks
we're gonna buy out some of this we're
gonna tell people to buy
it
I'm gonna take over like
that is
that is by far the emo I'm concerned the
most my okay so you're concerned the
most about that I've said numerous times
on this podcast
this is what goes on in the background
and numerous times on this podcast you
guys haven't laughed at me you guys have
told me I'm delusional that is not how
it works
just to clarify you don't think that the
the highest the Nintendo reading this on
Twitter and be like oh that's why these
individuals was buying stock because
they they might want to leverage it to
force us into emerge you don't think
that might you know make some bad blood
between them no no because they also
read the paperwork and it also said nah
Phil definitely said you know a hostile
takeover is not the option that we want
to go with that's right he also said
homeboy buying stock that we could use
to leverage our wage Hey listen we
forgetting valve name was in this
valve's name was in this also y'all nwb
yeah you gotta listen you always got to
have your options in order just in case
man and just in case the wedding don't
go how it's supposed to go
you know you always Gotta Have Jimmy
Dean at the door with the shotgun he
always got to be a shotgun wedding
sometimes man you know it could go down
nice we're playing a long game that's
right that's that man
I have too much ammo this is you don't
tell me somebody said nah I don't want
to go in there and forcefully I want her
to want me
I'm not gonna force myself
Yo Gotti the situations
I will be honest that particular email I
I do think that might cost
because it's just like
how is that even like something that
comes up in a conversation like yeah you
talking
I'm still taking just to be clear my
hustle takeover would not be something
that that would make a whole lot of
sense I want to say something real quick
uh this is involved we're like 140 away
from 20 000.
yeah hit that subscribe y'all 140 all
you got to do is get to 20K yo we're
giving y'all 20g we giving y'all this
emergency broadcast system we got solve
on the run for y'all like we giving
y'all content right now y'all so I gave
you the Lika like if you don't need it
again I mean that [__] the leak the face
of the leaker should definitely have
y'all give us those those songs
it looks like he really out though it
really like he did something and then
hold on I got a pen that it's like he
really did something look at the face
look at the look at the face
this is how you know Airport
right now so I was in Dr right now
chilling
I'm sorry
that photo was taken this morning
like why is he with the two yeah Becca
said he on his way to Dubai
those are the eyes of a white collar
criminal facts that dude getting away
with mad stuff facts that dude facts
could continue I don't even know whose
30 was I forgot now I lost track but he
was at it what yeah so who responsible
man who's that for who we coming for so
[Laughter]
I mean I could give you a thousand
different reasons of why
who did this who did that
does it matter in the end though City
with Tupac and Dion I'm done
to me it just I guess it just doesn't
matter in the end well we can sit here
we don't know who took these yeah it
this was the first time because remember
Nintendo remember old school Microsoft
tried this back in the day when they
first started with the DirectX team said
look you know we covered you they kind
of got laughed out the room you know
it's funny like people sitting there
like clowning uh you know feel for
wanting to get who wouldn't want
Nintendo in their Corner oh of course
not of course who wouldn't want Nintendo
in that like let's be real here Nintendo
and Xbox like this it's a wrap like yes
it's crazy I mean yeah that's weird the
best part about this and I'm telling
y'all y'all gotta look at his ambition
he didn't like the Microsoft try to get
Nintendo before and it got rebuffed got
laughed out the room
so you know what I'll do
I'm gonna do something that they didn't
do
I'm putting my name on the wall like his
his ambition is the most Bonkers I've
ever seen and we have some serious CEOs
in spots and you know and I got a
question I'm gonna have a question this
week I got a question now because of
this
we had the great Peter Moore on this
show
and we all know that man got some
ambition yes but but to see Phil's
ambition out here in these streets
I have to admit Peter we're going to
talk about it hopefully we get you back
on this Sunday
um
this is bro you can't say he's not a
dreamer you can't say he's not a
competitor you can't say that the things
that we're seeing that he said the other
thing that I like saying that and so I
don't know if you caught
well he talked about 2022 and how like
yo this ain't it like we got to we we
messing up the fumble in the back like
to see them verbalize all the stuff that
I felt I was like okay you know what I'm
saying and then obviously you know where
we at now right it's crazy but I'll jump
and kick if he was going to get you I
mean he says that he you know there's
people out there talking about he's not
trying no no you ain't trying to be
number one I mean I mean one of my own
pod podcast maze Brothers uh LLC
Partners one of them told me but they
weren't acting or trying to be number
one wait which one said that oh that's
all that's the one that's on the run I
wasn't me I know what I said
this guy right here this guy hold on
let's get that out again that guy right
there what's up you got something to say
for yourself
I mean to to be fair it this is all
stuff we're not supposed to know so yes
oh that's what you dying on
so now do based on what we know can we
confirm that Phil Davis Maximus really
expensive is an absolute competitive
Savage
Earth
so Delight lessons you even sound like
you do sound like you want to run right
now you sound like I'm in an echoey
place right now nah you good
yo cat daddy says you're doing it for me
to hold himself but continue
foreign
like this is scorched Earth really it
really is it is it's funny because we
always talk about how Colin you know
Collins takes to feel like they're very
PlayStation Fanboys and he says no but
when you see this it's like it is true
because they're like we're gonna spend
money on this
[Music]
from other parts of the company this is
not money that's coming in through Game
Pass and Xbox and then we just
reinvesting
exactly
we're going to
this Earth
thing it doesn't
move someplace else it doesn't matter
we're going to do this can I push back a
little bit though but I get where you're
going but remember it takes two to be
acquired someone has to want to be
acquired that's what I'm saying so you
can't just you can have all the money in
the world but Nintendo had laughed about
the room in the beginning right if you
look but if you look at this email yes
he's not giving up of course right
is isn't it one thing when you jump in
and you're a CEO of a company right
you've got to have a North star
you've got to have something that even
some people say you know what that might
not really be attainable but yo 10 years
from now we we we're always respond
you're never at a point where you're
like okay we did this we did this ABK
we're done we're the greatest y'all
right so my thing is a lot of it and I
get it because we're seeing it face
value and it I understand a lot of it
for someone's gonna look at creatures
and I feel when you said so I guess my
pushback is like I looked at it as this
is your pie in the sky
does it necessarily mean it's going to
happen but this is something that you're
a spying for it's just funny to see him
write it and say well yeah they don't
know just yet as far as like how good we
would be for them okay that's all I'm
saying I don't I don't misconstrue me is
saying is bad oh okay because the way
you make it it seem like they they just
out here and they gonna buy everybody
and everybody's gonna lay down and say
yes we're willing to be bored that's
what I'm trying to say okay
his willingness to just be like you say
no now
with your eyes with your eyes exactly
that really
really to me that's why I say a scorched
Earth where he's like I don't care how
long it takes what I have to do this is
the goal right right right so when I say
that it's it's like yeah any doubt any
questions about his motivations and
where he wants to go and the thing the
thing to take into account is this right
this isn't something that's new now this
isn't something that's recently right
you're right in my opinion when he went
to stop dealing with the plan to save
Xbox and in Game Pass and all this stuff
what came on facts this is something
that he had to bring us out there in the
beginning Versace to see this long-term
vision of of this domination of Xbox and
Game Pass thing to me the idea that
we're going to try to bring Nintendo
into the fold Warner Brothers into the
fold uh you know ABK whatever things of
that nature were part of that discussion
okay and looking at like King said the
fact that hey in the back of Xbox is
mine it's like oh you'll have to stop
the room all these years ago we're gonna
get you so I'm patient we're gonna get
you and this idea that that's still sort
of the North Star when I say sports
thirds because it's like no no matter
when no matter where I'll be there
I'll be there he vote but he's always
been that so he's always been he's
always been the dude when you front but
then the check don't clear and you can't
pay your rent yeah you know what I'm
saying and he's and he's rubbing your
back right and he'll be like exactly
he's got your he got your switch on his
Shelf
okay okay now this is gonna be slimy but
I gotta get it out of my head let's go
nah you're dancing in the club you're
like what up love you mommy buy you a
drink yeah it's like no leave me alone
no no no no no no we're not doing it
because that's the Rick Ross stuff
but take this so now she don't drink a
lot she's she's Tipsy she's in the
bathroom throwing up eat a hole in the
hair I'll get it out your face
is she gonna remember that oh you know
the nice save JoJo
homemade home make sure you got home go
home safe
that's it
yeah
even more right yeah let's go it was
such it was such a different time in
place then I didn't even know that that
was a thing to be thinking about like I
was going first of all I don't think
Xbox back then did not have the full
backing with Microsoft the way it
doesn't happen correct
um
but it's just this idea
we're just gonna take over every I'm
really interested to see what he feels
about what's transpiring today right
right we're going to talk about that
different time and place yeah so it's
interesting stuff man but I'll tell you
like again it's crazy because I know I
don't know I I honestly some of this
stuff obviously most of the stuff all of
this stuff was not supposed to get out
yeah I wonder what it does to those
relationships right yeah no good point
behind the scenes are they really having
conversations that are defunded and this
is nothing that any you know any person
in the know would not expect me in an
email somewhere it's like every time
Phil leaves Nintendo you know one day
you coming over right yeah you know one
day you're gonna be mine right
because he's saying like he think about
it his thing is like I don't care all
that success all those millions of
switches sold it don't matter none of
that matters your future is with us you
just don't realize it yet yeah yeah yeah
yeah look we gonna move on um as far as
this my thoughts was I even though it
was it we're hearing that it was you
know Microsoft that uploaded I'm still
gonna wait and Reserve judgment I think
it was something else I thought I had
something else on yeah once this FTC
stuff come up we'll take the news I'm
not saying the news is wrong I'm not
saying video kind of Chronicles was
wrong whatever I just want to wait until
more information comes out more details
is this a situation like how they each
the esa and someone put the file up on
the road they already they already got
they already got solved online oh yeah
we got solved all right so it is what it
is it is what it is what it says wait
what is oh they got solved
hold on
one of these men is in Dubai I can't
[__] it they are the [__] yo what
have we done that's it wow wow it's wild
out here it's wild out here but anyway I
don't know what's going on with the
joint but the pins is bugging but
whatever it is what it is so um we're
gonna move on what I was gonna say is
okay so we're gonna kind of combo this
because we're gonna we gotta move on a
little bit
so
now that all this is out
gotta talk about the competitor here
and we got to talk about attic we got to
talk about Sony and PlayStation
it cannot be like someone's best
interest that all of this stuff is out
there
system 2028 future plans 2030 for what
is it you know dominance of the industry
or you know them trying to take their
spot going for the number one spot by
the way you know that they literally was
saying that kind of energy
um yeah so what do you think as far as
um Sony's response and then we'll
combine it with the last topic which was
um the leak aftermath which is
um Phil actually came out with a
statement and this was today you know um
on referenced everything he says we've
seen the conversation the sad part is
everything was today yeah everything's
today we've seen that's an emergency ILP
we've seen the conversation around old
emails and documents it is hard to see
our team's work shared in this way
because so much has changed and there's
so much to be excited about right now
and in the future we will share the real
plans when we are ready that is fulfill
dominance Maximus are really expensive
today 4 30 p.m East just a few hours ago
this is what Phil had to say so what do
you think man
um
as far as you know Sony's response and
then Phil's response as far as it being
old stuff
um
I don't really think PlayStation could
say a whole lot you know they're going
to sit and probably first off they're
probably talking about how we uh they're
like uh they're like let's have a
meeting how we communicate in the
company uh you know maybe we should move
things off of emails you know if you got
if you got something to say You're Gonna
you're gonna you're gonna Zoom call me
we we ain't having no paper trail you
know especially if you have something to
say about the competition pick up a
phone and call me
we're not we're not being out there
exposed like this I I think Microsoft
will pivot to a degree I I know it's
like I said I I would assume some of the
things on that list have already been
pivoted from the time that they were
done right but I would say that is for
the most part
the the road map that they're doing and
and once you commit as much as they
probably have committed to this point a
lot of that can't be changed right so
they're going to have to you know pivot
what they can change I don't think this
is going to hurt Microsoft in the long
run hmm
because I do think that for the most
part this it wasn't public knowledge it
was like Common Sense knowledge
especially people in the industry but
it's not stuff like you know Oblivion
remake Fallout 3 remake it sucks that
those were leaked because those would
have been really good information like
this doesn't hurt
Microsoft in the industry this hurts
more of the consumers that watch them
than anything else it doesn't hurt
PlayStation because it hurts us you know
we we're not going to get EX like as
excited as we would have if we saw like
the Fallout thing happen live or
anything like that but as far as
PlayStation they they knew the majority
of this I I'm willing to bet you you
know there's some things that they
probably were surprised on maybe some of
the specs with the new Xbox series X and
maybe the fact that it that that it's
oval and not Square they probably didn't
know stuff like that but I would say
they had a good idea of where where
everything was going before this
happened
yeah I mean it is it is interesting to
see the response I gotta get it it's
just it's just like uh Twitter sticks
and all Oblivion remaster was leaked
like a lot of this leak just confirmed
previous leaks
now some of it did some some of it was
new a lot of it was new and Hardware was
in explicit detail and Visually explicit
detail but I understand what you're
saying from the game standpoint for the
game standpoint I want to get us it
solves back if not I'll get um King on
this but solve your back no you still
look he's still oh yeah I'm here all
right you're changing planes yeah yeah
you know he fueling the stuff
so big like what do you think the double
uh whammy here which is Sony now knowing
the Playbook
and for next year for potentially future
and then Phil's kind of response which
is like these are old documents this is
old information we will reveal the real
plan in due time and you know obviously
sad about what happened in the way it
was revealed
I think this is the overarching game
plan
um what's still to be set in stone is
the details right and that stuff is
still fluid you know but the overarching
plan I think that's what it is because
then at that point
you're inferring that they gave the
fdc's false information
right and they just gave oh no you give
give them that file
so obviously this there's truth to the
stuff that has come up
um so I don't think like Alex said I
don't think they pivot you know that is
the plan there are details within that
plan or something things that are still
being worked out but that's it and
that's why before what I was saying when
King push back a little bit and said
yeah you know Sony has to know where the
future is going but the thing about it
is when you're looking at this game plan
for the next console and it's super you
know this cloud-based hybrid thing
what I meant wasn't that Sony isn't even
remotely as prepared for that type of
future as Microsoft right so now they
see that that is a real pivot into that
corner I don't care how much how
preparation Tony has how many games is a
service Sony puts out there practice of
the matter is they are never and they
will never be as ready for a cloud-based
future as Microsoft did so to see
to see that their next console is going
to be this hybrid thing where the the
super big push into the cloud and really
getting being able to get the most out
of that technology in conjunction with
local hardware that has to be something
that they're looking at like oh do we
have to try to figure out a way to pivot
in this direction can we even do that
right
um because again I think the Sony game
plan is they dip their toes and stuff
you know hey here's this PS plus plus
plus thing where this kind of like game
pass but it's not
um you know hey this other side Hardware
you know all we need games as a service
so we can support our other big AAA
games to continue to make those things
the little little responses in the way
that they can to what Microsoft is doing
um this is different though right this
has been basing your entire next
generation of hardware on uh on an
infrastructure that you don't have a
hold on in the same way that Microsoft
does so that again is going to make you
think about what okay damn okay what do
we have to do moving forward so again I
don't think I think it's or Microsoft
they're they're still going to do what
they're going to do it just came out a
lot earlier than they expected to and
we'll go you know we'll find details
about it so Phil's saying that is you
know it still speaks saying hey yes the
details of this stuff have not come out
um while not acknowledging the fact that
this is probably true this is the
general idea of what we're going and
where we're going so I mean all of that
at the end of the day what does it do
long term I think adequate it on the
note it's it's not having that
excitement of oh what's coming next we
lost that moment with the Nvidia league
right with the Nvidia League when when
that started that when the first set of
batch of games started to come out and
you're like oh wait a minute this one
came out this one came out this one came
out then at that point you really do
start believing the rest of it and if
you believe in that then it's like damn
I'm not going to be surprised by
anything that comes out of pipeline so
it is that thing of you know when we're
at a summer game Fest or or maybe a
three if that ever comes back you know
we we're not as excited to see certain
things come out you know because we know
it's coming um and I've always even ever
since we gotten into this space you know
you get you guys have more connections
with people like that you know you guys
may know some stuff that I I tell you
explicitly don't tell me I don't care I
want to be surprised right I still want
to have that sort of surprise of Joy
um so yeah it's disappointing to know
all that stuff because you know
you have an idea about what's coming
obviously when the stuff is properly
announced by them they're going to tell
you the details and we'll have
discussions about the details and we'll
have discussions about what that means
for gaming in that moment in that place
in time
um so the discussions it doesn't stop
the discussions from happening but again
it's stuff that we're not supposed to be
perfect you are now and it's just the
reality we live in but um I think it's
going to be interesting to see
and it it just it feels like it's a
future that only Microsoft can do
considering their infrastructure and to
see where Sony pivots or doesn't pivot
or it's going to be interesting
um and that and that's that's pretty
much it no doubt King where we at Sony
the enemy got the paperwork you can see
the future what's going on and and you
know how do they combat that what's
their position and then obviously Phil's
statement about hey these are the old
documents we will reveal in due time the
the real plan so to speak as far as how
it's going to go so where you at with
this
well the Sony aspect of it is
we all know Sony is playing in a
traditional Hardware all right Sony is
going to sit there and they're going to
plan a hardware because that's what they
do they stick to the old metrics until
they are beaten ahead why are they
planning a hardware when they're not
going to be ps6 ah here we go if you
allow me to finish
you listen there's a lot of times people
plan to wake up in the morning but they
just don't stuff happens you know just
you can have the best laid plans it
don't mean it's gonna happen but you got
a plan right back to you King
you got to do this
[Music]
yeah no
it's just you know they're gonna have
their plans they're gonna they're gonna
be planning Hardware
in these next five years
the level of consistent games that's
going to hit Game Pass is going to make
it hard for them to keep up and I
believe by year three into this uh
five-year thing
they're going to look and say is it
viable for us to even compete
that's going to be it I told you it's
going to be a a fall see now they wanted
that fall for them to be a surprise
going to the next Hardware
the next Hardware is the space they
can't go to
um you can copy all the stuff that you
want to copy you can go to AMD like we
go to AMD you go to AMD we won the x86
chip we want the x86
you want to do SSD we gonna go with the
fast answers not the Mr B2 coach so you
know this dude has been copying and
copying and copying pasting homework all
the time
no Microsoft said
do this
don't do Game Pass properly you can't do
it you have the ability to do it but you
can't do it you can't do it right so
that's what Microsoft has been showing
you I I'd be since you've been studying
me I'ma start pulling the moves that you
can't do and I'ma show the people the
difference between me and you
um
so Sony and their arrogance is like so
what you can do a handstand because I
gotta be a handstand so what you can do
a handstand that's nothing I can do a
cartwheel
oh they came for the handstand uh
start doing more things that Sony cannot
do and one of those things is the cloud
infrastructure
that right there alone and dudes can sit
there and clown because y'all this is
what the distractors are gonna do
this is what the 2023 dudes is gonna do
now I know what 28 is about this 2023
news is living right now gonna bring up
Crackdown but this is what this show did
I'm telling you the fearing gonna happen
they're gonna say hybrid this is not the
future we want they're going to say that
they can do it all they want those are
the same dudes that didn't want TV and
didn't want digital
these are the same dude that told you I
don't want to look at the NFL on my box
and every Sunday they got a split train
watching us and watching football every
day
y'all watching Netflix on your your
PlayStation wait hold on I gotta cut you
you're so right because remember with
dudes like I don't want a camera it's a
spy thing and that dude's like Alexa do
this
you got a whole snitch in your house
see but the thing is the best part about
it is
you guys always complain about something
you don't want but then get it as soon
as you get it it's the greatest
I couldn't believe I was living without
this we know what site y'all go to on
your PlayStations we know this
we're not doing the problem but you know
that y'all not playing time on the board
of metrics we know what's really
happening with the haptic feedback
get this man
please he's out of pocket Ninja Turtles
got microphones and stuff this stuff
happening over there but y'all can do
that
but you can't do Cloud so y'all gonna
fear manga and talk about all this down
the third hey man now remember Crackdown
remember Crackdown all right
fear monger
2023 and 2028 I want you to go back five
years ago
um
are you the same person that you was
five years ago good point are you doing
the same things that you was doing five
years ago good point have you grown wise
or smarter more intelligent have moved
on and elevated yourself in those last
five years now imagine the company
that is a trillion dollar company
that has the greatest Minds working
there
and they have annual meetings to see
where the company is going to be in five
years they put projections and goals on
the boards these Engineers are trying to
change
the world
so I happen to know a fabulous engineer
whose mind is incredible
and
five years ago you would have not been
able to get the series X in that form
factor for that price
how they did it yeah but the engineers
were able to do it and they were so
proud of their work they dropped it off
the digital Foundry and said do with it
as you will
um I remember that and Austin Evans in
them
they gave it to everybody to check out
the work that's the first time
Microsoft
became
a Superior Hardware company
um
so now you have that company that is a
superior don't tell me they're not
better at you with software because they
knock your socks off with a software
game it's crazy
they're better at you in software
they're better at you in Cloud
and they're better at you in Hardware
um
now they're going to take the hardware
to a place that you can't go because
they're going to marry it the stuff that
you can't do
do you even show up to the fight I don't
think you show up to the fight I think
you're pulling no Moss I think you just
say no I think you pack it up and do
whatever you're gonna do I see these
leaks as troublesome
for certain crowd and certain
demographics it may be a warning sign
for Sony but at the same time I think
they so entrenched in the ways that they
do things that they can't pivot I think
in five years is not enough time for
them to be able to Pivot to change
what's inevitably about to happen to
them
okay
look I jump in man what what a week what
a week
um first part
I'll be honest I don't like
that that Sony get to see the Playbook
I think it's a disadvantage man I think
they could you know again to your point
King how much can they pivot you know
based on their plans
who knows but
it can't be good to see the vision next
year on a counter punch for a mid-gen
refresh so to speak it can't be the to
me that's not even the thing the worst
is the hybrid console future 2028
starter generation when they plan you
know to to do that
and then you know the 2030 and where
they see gaming and where they want to
be and and how ambitious they were so to
me
let's just say Sony was theoretically
caught with their pants down before this
information came out right your the
enemy has time to at least prepare now
for something that's coming so that's
the part it's like damn they lost the
element of surprise in the war right so
now the enemy can at least try to think
and counteract will they be able to take
it you know to the cloud probably not
but they may be able to reinforce their
own personal strategies and tighten up
what they do to say yo
you know we could try to come back in
this way if they go that way so that now
I mean for gamers is going to make it
better for us but I don't think it's to
Microsoft's best interest obviously so
that's that you know to
um Phil's comments you know I feel for
them I feel I I feel for that entire
team you know again no one wants
division revealed in this manner because
we don't have context we don't know what
this truly means we don't we can't see
it so now yeah we just see words on a
page and it's just like again you know
to me it just reminds me of like you
know when we read let's say we had the
documents for God of War 2018.
and it's going to be like yo Kratos
gonna have a son ain't no jump button
we're gonna be like what somebody said
what are you doing right that's what
we're gonna say over the show with this
story driven cradle no action nothing
that you used to so again it it I feel
for them because there's no context
there's no extra information is we read
in cold words on a page yeah and just
seeing it so it's just like you know and
again I I feel because I don't know what
if again theoretically what if they've
have an r d some of the latest
technology on the back end for cloud
that's truly going to change the
industry
we can't tell that with this right we
just hear hybrid cars this stuff comes
with a presentation right we usually
this stuff comes with the person that is
bringing it to the table explaining
stuff that's there right except for the
games and the road map with Bethesda I
think that stuff there was before they
got Acquired and then you know what they
wanted to release on their timeline yeah
no absolutely absolutely and you know
look last thing I'll say is just that um
it is interesting that to Saul's point
that he came out and addressed it so we
do know a lot of it was true right yeah
yeah because a statement came out right
so a statement came out you know to me
that's PR getting a hold of it and in
their defense yes there is some stuff
that is older and they're in a different
place on some things but we I agree with
solve I think the overarching vision is
still true the question is how much do
they pivot from that vision and so I got
Yo but um what a day
what a day um this is absolutely gaming
history you know as the law as we figure
you know we don't do this often but um
when something of this magnitude happens
you know we try to try to cover it and
try to cover it to the best of our
ability appreciate y'all coming through
last minute this was completely
unplanned again shout out to my brother
solve On The Run he did what he had to
do and we don't know if we're gonna get
him back but you know it is what it is
man it's all about the paper and the
clicks and the likes that he he did that
he's about the IOP we needed the clicks
we needed the 20K you know what I'm
saying we got to deal with NZXT now and
things is bubbling and my brother he put
his life on the line he's like look man
we got to put they've been inside we
putting their business out and we're
going to kick up 20K we're gonna hit the
20K or what what are we doing we're
gonna check what are we doing 20K yeah
y'all ain't subscribed yet my brother's
sacrificed y'all here
could y'all hit the 20K please could
y'all hit these likes because it's 826
let's go man my man is literally
switching fights he sees somewhere on
the run right now you know what I'm
saying dipping through TSA dudes want to
like it like it and subscribe stop
playing stop playing man we having fun
yeah you watching you wanted to hear
what I had to say live from Guantanamo
Bay
now listen I'm not gonna be around to
hit a super chess because I got to run
out you gotta run you gotta run right
but if there's anything pertaining to me
that you ask inside the Super Chat and
you want my answer to it they're gonna I
gotta go I gotta go too I think we
should just cover the Super Chat Sunday
nah I can't no no we can't do that I'll
read it I'll read it no no I'll read it
then I'll read them I'll read them but
I'll take care what I'm gonna do is if
any super chats are pertaining to me yes
we dress Sunday just no just just let me
know what they are and I'll answer them
I'll answer you on Twitter if you're on
Twitter I'll definitely answer you
directly on Twitter whatever it is for
me got you um I do apologize
this is family stuff no I'm just letting
them know all you know because normally
we don't do this at this time yeah right
is it school night is it work night I'll
be back you know I gotta drop my son off
you know um take him to the gym he work
out we work out he eat and stuff like
that so I gotta drop out I love it
that's right man bro I'm loving that
you're back on your gym yeah all every
day every day
I'm also not gonna do a whole lot of
things like everybody else else do you
know
why you got to do it like that yo listen
I'm gonna leave that right there I'm
gonna let that stink in here
you stupid but for sure for sure oh yeah
yeah I just gotta run drop them off and
I'll try to zoom back in and still catch
up but um love you guys for showing up
we had almost 1500 strong on on an
impromptu Tuesday I appreciate you guys
and we we turn
um Taco Tuesday into something different
I think so for what he did but um now
I'm a Man On The Run he's about the team
he sacrificed it all for the team and
that's what it's about right now you
know so if you know his audio is going
to be a little sketchy for the next
couple of months please understand
please I heard I heard I heard um El
Chapo help him get it we try to Grant
Asylum
he's going through Ecuador
try to see you can give my brother Safe
Haven right now okay you're doing this
difficult time
a VPN it's all over the place
I saw any outro for you I'll hold it
down any outro for you
hear me yeah
okay yeah yeah
um yeah the last one last thing is funny
on this side let's go knowing the road
map that I forgot to mention
in the short term in the short term I
think it affects them more it affects
Microsoft more because when you look at
you know the refreshes the refreshes are
not a pro right so it's it's it's a
willingness to give up the power
narrative at least for the back end of
this generation if there is a pro that
comes out right so now you got to deal
with that and I'm to King's Point at
that point the hope is that game pass is
popping the way it's supposed to be
popping and you combat it with that yeah
but again these consoles their refreshes
they're different uh form factors that
have other quality of life changes but
they are not more powerful so if there's
a PS5 Pro or whatever that comes out
they will retake that power narrative
for the back end of this generation and
we'll see how much that matters right
because we saw with the PS4 Pro and and
the Xbox One X it didn't matter so much
because it's just a hardcore that's
going to jump on those things
it's not really you're not bringing in
new people with that necessarily right
especially if you're offering some sort
of slim version at that point too I
think they're going to be doing as well
so um you know it doesn't really matter
but again it's a narrative that's going
to go back into their corner at least
for you know a couple of years right so
that's something to consider in the
short term no it's a good point yeah
yeah
again I took one for the team
I had to do what I had to do put the
work out there and then immediately hop
on a plane and make sure you know that
my family's safe but you know I had a
contingency plan all along and I was
ready for this day
and we appreciate you man just be safe
out there make sure you change up your
phone numbers every now and then exactly
yeah I got the burners
so uh I I don't know where I'll be
coming from on Sunday
hopefully Peter will appreciate you know
you going through extra you know
exteriorating circumstances to make it
happen so you know we appreciate you
family don't get back what you got to do
love you yeah
thank you guys for rocking this is a
beautiful thing love you too brother I
appreciate you taking the stupid chats
yeah they're gonna be as smooth as you
but I do the best I can while you wanna
run do what we got to do exactly
I would build down all right roam I'm
gonna hold y'all down give me a second
I'm gonna try to get my best saw voice
going together and uh yeah let's try to
take care of the super chassis y'all
came through in droves for us for this
emergency podcast so again shout out to
hopefully this is not um let me put it
on me for a second Penn's been acting
weird today I gotta fix a new computer
y'all so I gotta bear with me um
Nintendo on the otaku the homie ten
dollars or Super Chat we respect Phil
he's a good kid sometimes he just gets
ahead of himself he'll be blowing up our
phone talking nonsense though I don't
want to have to send out the Nintendo
ninjas he needs to call that listen man
he had his eye on y'all man he just said
y'all don't know what's good for y'all
yet you know give them time hey I did
take the 10-year deal you took the
10-year deal so hey relationships you
know did improve since that uh that that
email we could at least say that
um let's do God Emperor suffocating five
dollar Super Chat Phil is that dope
people said he didn't have that dog in
him man it's ruthless Whitfield well
yeah one thing we learned is ambition
the ambition of Phil Spencer is truly
remarkable that man death definitely
Shoots for the Stars he ain't playing
out here shout out to lockdance on show
Repco remember for 35 months good
afternoon Lords I can't believe the
series has conspired with Psalm to leak
all of those documents but man I guess
Xbox isn't going anywhere huh yeah shout
out to the series that shout out to a
revision of the series s
um shout out to yeah good point about
Xbox not going anywhere it looks like as
far as the commitment to console is
still there I think a lot of people were
very fearful of that so I think we
learned that you want me to pick up some
of them now um yeah I do like two
morning jumping uh Starlight 137 with
the two-pound Super Chat I'm scared of
Phil spender he is done playing yeah
yeah these emails again ambitious
ambitious targets yeah baby father five
dollar Super Chat shutter in Terror and
witness the rise of dark field devour
not the Galactus reference oh man the
vowel over he's outside y'all again
intentions are being made very clear
what you got
we gotta find this project from Thomas
Serrano uh fgc the biggest
opponent Ops will pull up and teach him
got a member chat for 26 months from
[__] Jay oh Dominus Maximus
shoe enough Spencer enough respect so
that's best to show enough got a member
chat for 39 months from heated heavy
505. King got that refresh Xbox from the
DVD man
shout out to eat it from Chris my combo
Combi or I don't know whatever one man
uh who whatever's one's Main and m key
for uh uh so far uh rating for me I
actually uh like Kenji you like Kenji oh
that's what's up yamakun Lao main so
salute that let me get oh sorry uh five
dollars per chat from Michael uh Michael
Mooney at hybrid
x86 arm design would uh would keep
backwards compatible and add mobile game
support to console yes good catch I was
thinking about that forgot to mention
the mobile number such yeah that that is
Forward Thinking and the cloud part
again I just want to be clear because a
lot of people are getting scared with
when they hear console Cloud hybrid but
we also have to think about mobile games
and their commitment to mobile and and
the importing there and backward compact
that's a good catch Michael Mooney I
forgot to mention that three dollar
super shot from just bring it 4K 60
Zelda got me feeling beefy in my shorts
yay five dollar super trap from hustle
and motivate there was extremely
arrogant I feel to say that about
Nintendo as the switch is out selling
everyone I think let me let me comment
on that I I do think I understand
people's anger just to hear Nintendo
mention but
um in In fairness out before they had
Tegra and before the switch two stuff
you know Hardware was always a kind of a
little issue for them so I understand
his mindset of what to make that happen
but to your point two it takes two
detectors so my Nintendo has to want to
do that as well and it looks like they
you know they they're fine right now
this is where they are two two dollar
super trap from Michael Patton I'm
trying to do something uh Phil Spencer
is King Brad five dollars per draft from
James Hill unless Phil has a hundred
billion plus check Nintendo will laugh
that man out of the room again hey he
ain't completely laughed out because
they took a 10-year deal after this with
Call of Duty so the relationship is
still cozy now what happens now after
this information is out it's a whole
nother situation yeah we got a member
chat from Rambling entertainment he's
been a member for one month crazy how
the leaks came out a day after it was
revealed uh the uh Elder Scrolls six
Elder Scrolls six was PC and Xbox only
Ward says it was an error from Microsoft
but one came from another after another
yeah I think it was just uh I think that
was probably the start of the leagues uh
Jared back five dollar scripture Xbox
has no games traumatized Xbox last gen
this new Xbox is the result we've been
seeing gaming done on the scale Xbox
World Order is a real thing okay I Gotta
Throw us out twenty dollar super trap
from uh WV Harp guitar
shout out to the Lords in the realm and
a huge shout out to Cog I appreciate you
your friend it's so great seeing you
back and healthy thank you Justin oh
Justin I remember you appreciate you
brother and um thank you yeah I'm doing
much better each day each week a little
stronger a little better I'm getting
back to myself and I'll say the last
week is finally the first time I start
to feel myself but still more work to be
done but thank you five dollar Super
Chat from Johnny benzo yo General King
did you see the leaked emo where
Microsoft confirmed that Sony isn't
making a ps6 question mark all hell IOP
I see that email but yeah nobody also
with the GDC head of Xbox game
publishing said that had like over 10
million games of development over there
so with that under the pipeline is
insane that's crazy five dollars from
Kevin back uh Baskerville uh PSX like
Dollar Tree raising prices to save in
business wow five dollars yet from uh
from bleaches yeah
why don't people realize series X is the
mid-gen refresh it just happened to
release on the same days as main console
the series s I've been seeing that
narrative interest fight off scripture
from Ellis PlayStation with the
emergency stay to play 2.0 anytime now
deep dive into baby steps five dollars
hybrid as they are doing with Microsoft
flight simulator but on steroids not to
say hardwood will not be capable hold on
let me get my man that's my man
dreadpool met him up in Florida um I
want to comment on that um yeah look I'm
eating I got you go yeah I got you yeah
dreadpool the hybrid thing is
interesting that's why I'm telling
people pump the brakes I see what you're
saying because fight similarly use a lot
of that stuff in the background and as
far as the um calculations the
navigation the map system the Bing or
whatever
I'm more on that type of energy as
opposed to oh it's going to improve the
graphical for that they're going to get
more teraflops out of cloud compute I'm
not on that part but again you know I'm
not privy to 2000 you know 20 28 and
what where Tech's going to be but I I
see where you're going to dribble and I
tend to align with what you're saying
there shout out to Dean Rivera 10 super
chat one of the documents has Phil
saying that if by 2027 they didn't have
enough Game Pass Subs they would exit
the console Market I love Xbox and hope
that's not true thoughts on those
comments for him I didn't see that
document I did see documents on Game
Pass projections and I did see the PC
projections that they had was much
higher than they actually got which they
were they were a bit off base on that
one but um yeah we'll see I think that
to me when I see the 2028 vision
you know that they're still looking to
be in it as far as console that's what
that's the most I got of it but I will
agree that yeah they got to be internal
targets they have to hit as far as um
Game Pass for them to be in a
sustainable state so we shall see Pony
up two dollars for the chat new series X
looks like a disc but can't take a disc
I know that like a cylinder no doubt
Gerald Mack the OG five dollar Super
Chat haptic feedback on a new controller
and two terabytes I think it's a fair
trade-off for the loss of the Blu-ray
player I think a little I feel you look
I like that I like everything that's
going on my only thing is which I
brought to King is it can't be 500 and
let's just say the PlayStation 5 Pro
somehow it's 500 that's a problem
because you can't have your competitor
with a more powerful thing at the same
price they should that would be a lesson
from the Xbox one versus the PlayStation
4 era so I think if they do know it's
PS5 is 500 they got to come lower but if
they figure it's higher than they'll
stay at five death side two dollar Super
Chat King David is addressing the Xbox
Nation hey hold the line yeah he was he
was in his bag he was holding me he was
definitely in his back shout out to
Spartan 661 200 Super Chat Jr is hiding
because Order 66 has been initiated all
right let's see what Jim Ryan you know I
know for one thing they definitely look
at them documents and see how they going
to respond rubber knob with the five
dollar I'm gonna say Australian and now
it's Microsoft turned to sue the FTC
this is the greatest comedy show ever
yeah this is wow what a leak insane
um mad0410 member for 41 months is that
the new haul worth Xbox cheer yes it is
shout out to the good members of whole
earth with the chair I love absolutely
love it been rocking it for a while just
my first time setting it up because I
wanted to set it up with the new you
know what I'm saying the new rig right
now but yeah this thing is comfortable
as hell I love it it is I'll put some
pictures up on Twitter I was meaning to
do it just today emergency podcast but
yes it is the whole world uh XBox
exclusive game evening line chair and is
very comfortable shout out to Samar Sam
hours I can't pronounce Mr cr40 fat out
Super Chat until Phil's email I thought
this was a Wrath of con move since the
FTC couldn't get a judge to block the
APK first so now all bets is off now
that they their path is clear I see what
we doing let's see what we doing Robert
Kelly with the two dollar Super Chat
surprise IOP yeah we had to do it for
the country y'all can't wait to watch
that this is a good one this is really
fun we had soft jokes for days Jonas the
dad two dollar Super Chat solved in the
walls running from ages
The Matrix no doubt Robert Kelly did you
pop off Sid close by it too yeah bro I
was so happy y'all know how much I love
ghostwire Tokyo I know it's flawed I
know it's not perfect but the premise is
so amazing the combat with the hand bro
I've been wanting to see they don't even
need to do aboard it's still condensed
fix the graphical man I'm excited you
got me Robert Kelly two hours with chat
so General King excited to see Mario and
Halo I will bring that to King's
attention shout out to spartan661 to our
Super Chat soft is DB Cooper right now
taking that money haha facts good
reference I like that spot six six one
two dollar Super Chat Xbox is showing
that they can do a text yo they are
wallet Robin Kelly two hours in the chat
so that's what joystick does in real
life damn wow I'm gonna leave that alone
and then we got Grail night five dollar
Super Chat how much do I need to Super
Chat to be able to listen to the show
after the fact currently working night
shift so I can't stick around all hail
IOP well it'll be up on um YouTube
channel so you can still listen to it
you know as soon as it finishes go
online I don't know if we're gonna have
the audio because I I we did not tell
kaibatsu about this so but this is an
official IOP episode most likely there
will be no time yeah
we just freestyle put it together last
minute Necromancer sale 10 super chat
thank you thanks for the Emergency show
guys thank you have a good evening
everyone yeah we try to do it for it uh
Robert Kelly two dollar Super Chat solve
is on the Run damn he killed Joyce you
murdered the lover I'll pick up super
trap from Tom 909
uh Saul didn't kill joystick he just
dared to play whoa whoa two dollar super
trap Spartan 661 solved everyone misses
you when you are not on IOP facts
two dollars to attract from fee and mate
hey hey Amari yeah I guess meth cast guy
has the most clickbait video ever come
on be nice
no personal attacks and no personal
attacks come on five dollar super
attract from Jeff Newton Microsoft must
not be happy about this league do you
think Microsoft proper may go after FTC
League yeah I mean I've been through his
fault yeah it depends on F4 if they have
proof that they are not at fault yeah
you best believe they are going to take
action but uh yeah that's what I got
shot de la I mind that [__] yeah this
chair is amazing I I cannot go back to
my other one so salute and again it
salute to everybody that pulled up
drunken ninja thank you he said love
y'all for doing it Defcon yeah it was
definitely emergency broadcast system
situation attic you want to say anything
to the Fine people before we get up yeah
I'm assuming you guys over there to J
main nice
um I think Jamie's a great content
creator to go over there
so say IOP raid man I want all of you to
go over there and say that hit that like
button obviously if you know you've been
here for like two hours you can't be
there that long that's fine but he's a
good content Curry go get him some um
some motivation to continue making
content but I appreciate everyone coming
through we had like over like 1400
people yeah this was crazy this is for
the culture so much love really
appreciate y'all again excuse the
technical difficulties I'm still
figuring things out when the new rig
shout out to NZXT he's supposed to get
all the love we got for NZXT very beefy
emergency episode I see you ask your
Patty King being messy but uh yeah this
is fun again a moment in gaming history
usually these type of moments we try to
cover and this was one that couldn't
wait uh appreciate the support the
reason why another reason why we did it
is because we intend to have Peter more
back for part two of um our our show we
you know obviously we the Sega the Sega
talk the Dreamcast talk the 360 talk we
didn't get into the EA we got to talk
about the unity era he was at Union this
man has a story career is that Reebok
unit name it owner of our Liverpool
Football Club so there's still a couple
of Chambers we got to get into and um
yeah we will talk that with him and we
want it to be fair because this was such
a news topic and we probably that show
let's be real would have been like eight
hours let's be real between Peter Moore
this or it's too much going on but um
yeah anyway I appreciate y'all we will
see y'all son again thank you all around
for pulling up last minute did this for
the culture addict any final case
appreciate it for coming through man and
definitely uh you know shout out to uh
to Travis for doing the interview we did
an interview on you know the state of
reviews and the the gaming industry and
definitely you know J main man
afterwards click that button man go over
there and say hi you guys have a good
day all right we out of here everybody
enjoy your Sunday [__]